If you don't win, it's okay.
It's all right.
Don't worry about that.
You know, unless it's Sunday, then it's not okay.
And we're having fun.
We're having fun.
Guys, we're having fun.
Good luck.
Have fun.
We can all fall back on our regular 9-5s.
Don't worry about it.
This is my 9-5, though.
No need to stress.
Oh, no.
Let's go, Dougie.
Let's go.
Yes!
Okay, okay.
Get going.
He's burnt.
Wait, how come that grab didn't go through?
Don't worry about it.
Get in there.
Nice.
There you go.
Yes!
You can just hit her again.
Okay.
Nice!
Get her ass!
Come on!
Oh, no.
It's all right.
No worries.
No biggie.
Health is a resource.
All right?
That's just the tax.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeehaw, baby.
Okay.
She doesn't know.
She can't see.
No!
I like it.
You're absolutely insane, dude.
Dougie, I'm nice key, dude.
Dougie, I'm nice bird.
I don't think the delay is that much.
My turn.
I literally just saw it in real time.
Are you one and done, her?
That's my turn.
Listen, you're concerned about player two.
That was the freest match I've seen for you on player two ever.
True.
I think you got it.
I don't think you gotta worry about this.
Don't sell yourself short, Dougie.
You messed up my spectator.
There's no left or right when you press triangle, so you got this.
I'm back in there.
I'm in.
Nice!
Oh, my God.
I felt that.
I'm excited here.
I gotta calm down.
Come on!
Nice punish!
I just covered that.
Let's go.
What?
I'm getting too excited here.
The lab work is paying off.
Oh, man.
It's about to be the freest match.
I won't hold back.
I'd be scared to go in.
I'd be scared, too.
Nice.
Good job.
Yeah!
Good jump over.
You're mine!
I am almighty!
Next DI, you get level 3.
Okay.
That was a good attempt.
That was really smart.
That's one!
It's over!
Let's go!
The freest match I've seen!
Oh, my goodness.
That was dopey!
Dude, training matters!
The training paid off!
That was night and day from last time.
You played so...
You knew the matchup.
Good job!
That was so sick, dude.
Training does work.
I call that revenge.
For Ultima, the only thing about Ultima SK is that this guy DI's randomly all the time.
But he also knows how to counter DI.
So, just chill on your DI and punish his.
You know how to punish that now.
And do everything you know how to do.
You got the training.
I have been waking up at night to counter DI's.
So, he will throw DI randomly and you will cook him for it.
I've been downloading those one-hour videos with random DI's splattered here and there.
No, I didn't even download it.
I made it.
It's so much worse.
She created it.
You made it yourself.
She's the mad scientist herself.
That's crazy.
Alright, here we go.
Woah!
It's the blaze over.
Nice break.
Nice!
Now you can use DI yourself.
Let's go!
That's alright.
You can learn from the next one.
When you do it against him, right?
No, he countered DI's.
That's the only thing.
Don't use DI against him when he has meter.
Jesus Christ, he does so much damage.
That's Luke, baby.
Nice, that's fine.
Take the throw.
Very good.
That's close.
You're seeing it.
Just let him wake up.
He's in neutral.
Your drive rushes are great.
Just let him wake up.
Good defense.
You're sick with it!
That's insane!
Yeah, rush him down.
He has no meter, so you can eat a DP.
It's fine.
Let's go!
He's burnt out.
Do it again.
Have you punched a DI?
It's fine.
It's over.
Just chill.
No way!
It's alright.
Composure.
No worries.
Sorry, he stuffs so much HP.
Let's get out of the corner.
Nice.
Nice!
It's fine.
You're playing better than him.
Very close.
You know the game plan.
He's just YOLOing a lot.
And it's like, wow, he's really doing that.
You know what I mean.
Nice.
Combo!
Get her!
You could've still grabbed him there.
Have you punched a DI when you get him in the corner?
Yep.
Rush him down.
Combo!
Eske, you're so sick.
Let's go.
It's okay.
No worries.
Just do it again.
You're gonna chip him out.
Yeah, you can just jab.
Exactly.
Let's go.
Eske.
Fine.
Nice defense.
That eating a throw is totally cool.
You're good.
Get him.
Okay, just chill on the meter.
That's fine.
Just chill.
Nice.
Nice defense.
Yeah, just chill on the meter.
Nice.
Now you can use meter.
You're good.
You have your super.
Okay, that's alright.
Yeah, just let him wake up.
Oh, nice.
Oh, no meter.
Yeah, just chill on the DI.
He's just gonna jump.
He's just jumping whenever he's in burnout.
Nice.
Oh, I love it.
Oh, nice combo.
See, he's just gonna jump.
There we go.
Oh, you're sick with it.
Oh, nice again.
Oh, let's go.
Eske!
You have the game plan.
You adapted so good.
Yeah.
Yeah, the only thing.
You figured it out.
When he's burned out, don't do DI right away.
He's gonna leapfrog.
Wait to get a clean heavy punch into DI.
And you got this.
Nice.
This is perfect for you.
Perfect for you.
Nice.
Nice DI.
Heavy punch into DI.
Oh, that's good too.
Yep, guaranteed.
Oh, you're so sick, Eske.
Let's go.
That's okay.
Just keep it cool.
Keep it cool.
No worries.
He's in the corner.
He's gonna jump.
Nice grab.
Just chill.
Yeah, you're good.
Nice.
Let's fucking go.
That's my goat.
Oh my god, kill her.
No.
Nice DI kick.
That's cool.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
If you get in, just dry rush medium.
Okay.
Nice.
That's fine.
Just block it out.
He's gonna try to...
Let him wake up DP.
That's fine.
Guys, call out Eske.
Let's go.
Holy shit.
Eske, in two days, you have become a Street Fighter fucking player.
Oh my god.
Nah, she's goaded with the sauce, dude.
She's so sick.
I'm gonna kick the street gun out.
You have learned so much.
I left the room again.
I don't know what to do.
It's okay.
Listen, you win, you can do whatever you want.
Let's go, Eske.
That was amazing.
Oh my god.
I know her.
Alright, Bravo.
You better 3-0 this.
No pressure.
Hold on a minute.
We gotta play.
What is the point of pressuring me?
You're already used to it.
You didn't take it.
No shot, dude.
We're freaking on a streak and Doki decides to jinx it.
Oh god.
No pressure.
No pressure, though.
She won her match.
Now it's time to...
Oh, gloves are off.
Everyone.
Esfan just...
He neutral jumps at a distance a lot.
He plays very patient, too.
Yeah, yeah.
Just don't go...
Don't whiff too many knees on him.
He likes to go to the air a lot.
That's about it.
You got this.
Let's go, Weepy.
Whoa, whoa.
Dragon Ball Z.
Every time, man.
Nice!
Yeehaw!
Let's go.
Too good, dude.
Too good.
Oh.
He's scared.
You tried to do your signature move.
Just chill with the knee on him.
He's just gonna jump back and do weird shit.
Yeah, just punish.
That's extremely punishable.
Sorry, that was too much pressure.
Okay.
We're now...
It ain't over yet.
Just chill.
He's gonna do something unsafe.
Just walk him down.
Oh, suck!
The fucking suck!
Oh!
Oh, sick!
Who is this guy?
Yep, sweet.
You can sweep that in return.
Nice.
It's alright.
Huge.
Punish that with SPD.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
We're good.
Oh, this is close.
Oh.
No way!
Does that work?
Oh, you're so sick!
Oh, the reaction!
That was amazing!
Oh my god, the reaction!
Holy shit!
Yeah, so just let him wake up.
And he's gonna do neutral jump in your grill every time.
It's time to lariat his ass, man.
If he gets a knockdown.
Yeah, don't even fucking bother teching a throw against him.
Oh, you know he's tilted.
He's tilted.
Get him.
Get his ass.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Oh my goodness.
One day I'll be able to do that.
Yeah, just let him do something weird.
Yeah, he wakes up dumb.
Oh, nice!
Oh, man!
This is clean.
You know you ain't gonna get command grab.
I love it.
Holy shit!
He's scared, dude.
He's gonna be dreaming tonight, dude.
He's so locked in.
He's back in New York City.
Yes, sir.
Don't play it on me, player.
You know how to get Oki.
You're safe.
Oh, that was good block though.
Oh, he's killing himself now.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
Just block it out because he's gonna jump.
Oh my God.
You're so lucky.
Oh, he's killing him.
Oh my God, dude.
Almighty!
God, that damage is outrageous.
Don't burn yourself out and you win.
Oh my God!
Jackhammer!
Let's go.
Easy.
Get down.
Get the fuck down.
That was so sick, dude.
Oh my God.
Oh my goodness.
Alright, Cole.
Are you gonna break our streak?
God, I need to go to the bathroom so bad.
I'm using this piss buff right now.
You can go.
You can stall.
Are you sure, man?
No, it's fine.
This is the piss buff.
This is it!
I'm about to show you right now.
Alright.
Are you gonna show us?
I don't know if I need to see it.
No, I'm talking about the performance.
Not anything else, you sicko.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, look at that above 1500 MR.
Flexing out a room.
Why do you leave the room, dude?
Gotta reflect.
Let's go, Cole.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Oh, that threw a loop.
Oh, no more loop.
A team of all grapplers.
That's this game, man.
Oh my gosh.
What the fuck did I just watch?
Yes, sir.
Oh my goodness.
That's burnt.
Oh, nice!
That's the round.
Go, clean.
I really like Aki now.
Should be scooping.
Oh, I see the tricks.
Her movement is really cool in general.
Nice defense.
You're good.
How can he be part of the Fee Fighters when he's playing character with shoes?
Not committed to a bit.
Nice jump out.
Does he have a car?
Did you cross him with no shoes too?
Yes.
He's a fraud.
He needs to lock in.
Oh my god, look at the anti-airs.
That's fine, he's burnt.
You're in control.
Yep.
I messed up.
That's cool.
That's fine.
It's all right, we give those one round.
Just to make them feel better.
Nice.
Nice big throws.
Yeah, I almost had it.
It's all good, man.
That was close.
Oh, nice.
Poison him.
One more.
He's scared.
Very nice.
I saw the vision.
You got the new toy.
Yeah.
I'm going to get it today, coach.
I'm going to get it.
He had to tech chat.
He had to tech.
We'll know when he lands it.
Never mind.
Nice defense, man.
The control.
Yes, sir.
Pop that poison.
Keep him in that corner.
Don't let him leave.
Lay down the puddle.
Yes, sir.
Set.
Play, baby.
Hold this.
It's all good.
One mistake he had to capitalize.
Yeah, he just wants to make him feel better.
I hate that.
Oh my god.
You're killing it, man.
Let's go.
The shimmy on the floor makes me so uncomfortable.
Get off the floor.
Oh, what the fuck was that?
Dude, your movement is so good.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
The slithers.
Nice.
That's good.
Good news for the medium punch.
True.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Just can't do anything.
Yep.
Very nice.
Oh my god.
It's getting cooked.
That shit's so tilting, too.
Oh my god.
Roll loops are cool when your teammates is over.
Yeah.
Let's get it.
Oh my gosh.
He needs a miracle.
We're good.
No miracle for him.
Oh my goodness.
Nice job.
Nice.
You're dealing with the fireballs.
Your anti-fireball movement was so much better already.
And you jumped out of the corner like 30 billion times like I told you.
Let's go.
That was so good.
Awesome.
Nice.
Now you can go pee.
You don't have to watch the coach.
Okay.
Did he leave already?
Sorry.
Okay.
Just keep it chill.
We'll just cheer you on.
I'm going to lower you guys volume for me.
Okay.
We won't make you laugh.
Top tier.
JV trying to get those five points.
Those five points for his team.
They need it.
Wait.
Didn't we have 36 yesterday?
We already have half of the points.
We had 39.
But like the other teams...
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, we did really good.
Also, Bronpo, Fumi got a point off Roy.
It's possible.
I remember you played around with Fumi.
So maybe he can get a point off Roy too.
I believe.
Sorry stream.
I left you on read.
Well, they started when I didn't realize.
It's all right.
Dragon Ball Z time for you.
Dragon Ball Z.
Super fast water.
Nice.
Nice grab.
Punish kill.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my god.
That's insane.
Nice.
Oh my god.
This is what happens when we don't distract the coach.
Yeah.
I feel so bad now.
We're holding it back.
Oh, that was good.
Rashid is so obnoxious.
Oh my god.
Whose idea was it?
Holy shit.
We can't have conversations.
We can't talk about it.
Oh, my bad.
Okay, sorry.
He needs full focus, especially against Rashid.
Fall.
Into the ball you go.
How does he hit it every time?
Oh my god.
This is why he's meta.
Look at that pretty boy right there.
Look at him.
He slowed the fight down.
I can actually see it.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, what do you do here?
Just block it?
I think so.
That's fine.
We'll take those.
Yeah, it's just one little hit.
He can steamroll like this.
That's Rashid's special.
Oh no.
No, you did really good though.
Yeah, you're in his head.
You're in his head.
You played really good though.
If Rashid was slightly worse, you would have won that.
Yeah, if he was rank 121, you would have won that.
Oh god.
Look at my watching.
Rashid, bro.
So stupid.
He's super hard to play too, right?
No, not really.
Oh.
Why aren't we playing Rashid?
Because he's stupid.
Oh, nice.
Oh, here we go.
Nice.
I think that's it.
Yeah, it's over.
So dumb.
I hope Capcom butchers this character, bro.
I hope Capcom is watching.
They're most likely watching.
And then before they nerf instead.
It's Geef's time to shine.
Nice.
I'm so close.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Level 2.
Let's go to the corner.
Fuck it, we ball.
Ball time.
Oh, you're mine.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, the bait.
That's dead.
Stand still.
Hey, stand still.
Yeah.
You have the right to remain silent.
Nice.
Oh, I don't know if you can get anything out of that.
I don't play it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, God.
Here we go.
Tornado's coming.
Tornado warning.
Oh, nice.
There you go.
To the corner.
Your teammate left the lobby.
Fuck it, we ball.
Oh, he didn't do the big one.
Oh, yes.
Oh.
Nice hit.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Just get out.
That's what I'm talking about.
Let's fucking go.
Dude, this is like a night and day difference from fucking Wednesday 2.
Yeah.
He's playing so good.
The coach is like Batman, dude.
Just some prep work is all he needs.
He can beat anyone.
He just needs us to shut up.
That's it.
Oh, nice grab.
Yes, sir.
He's so good.
That was good.
Oh, yes.
Okay, that's insane.
Oh, yeah.
Mix up.
Oh, he started dancing.
Oh, my God.
That fireball is so stupid.
What the fuck?
Nice.
Get him.
Let's go.
That's insane.
I think that's death.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Just barely.
He's scared.
What the fuck?
How does he predict that?
Just barely.
He's so scared.
Oh, God.
I'm so scared.
Oh, no.
Oh, God.
You're sick, man.
You're sick.
My booty hole is so clenched right now.
Oh, my God.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, my goodness.
The corner.
You'll just never be in the corner against Rashid.
That's very hard.
Yeah.
What the fuck am I looking at?
What the fuck?
Locking in.
Yeah, we're locking in.
Let's go.
They're both adapting to each other.
Here we go.
Touch the toes.
Don't let him touch the floor.
Pull.
Ah,
the burnout.
It's hard.
Oh, no.
Oh, nice.
Oh, good punish.
Good punish.
Nice try.
That was close.
That was so close.
That was way better than last time.
Incredible set, dude.
One of the undefeated.
It's okay.
That was awesome.
That's all right.
They needed those points anyway.
But, no.
That fight was incredible.
Yeah.
That was insane.
That was so good.
Rashid is so...
I will forever be a Rashid hater for the rest of my life.
That was so close.
That was good.
That was a good match.
It was.
I knew when you got him in the corner, I was like, dude, he's going to jump out.
And he did.
Fuck.
But that was so hard to stop Rashid from jumping out.
It's just part of it.
Yeah.
Yeah, because he can mix up his timing of coming down and...
Oh, God.
He needs a wall jump.
Yeah, that shit is...
There's too much stuff going on.
That was awesome.
Yeah, against a rank 120?
That shit was insane.
We got to stop, Dokie.
We got to stop.
You're killing me every time you talk about their rank.
I'm not going to lie.
That rank...
Don't...
Let's just move on.
That's not the point.
It's JB.
It's just JB.
It's just Nephew.
We'll beat their asses.
You don't understand.
He's rank 110.
Yeah.
Those numbers are so not important.
Oh, man.
Those are so unimportant ones.
This is the difference with fighting games.
We're just human and we're going to beat their asses.
Not wrong.
I don't care if you're number one or number 210.
You're getting your ass beat.
There we go.
That was good shit.
I think everybody played way fucking better.
Like, it's crazy.
Yeah, I think we played pretty good.
That set the tone.
I think we're in a good spot.
Dude, I'm surprised with the SK.
SK made that adaptation like on the fly.
That was sick.
Yeah.
They started beating up on DPs and...
Oh, that was awesome.
Doki, you let her get a chance.
Yeah, that was insanity.
Oh, my God.
Finally.
And then BrawlPro over there styling.
It's like, all right, let me play.
I'm in training room right now.
You're just like, I also got coached.
I got coached by Justin.
Damn, I got to get coached by Justin now, too.
Hey, I coach all of you and you're all winning.
True.
But we can take it one step further beyond.
Every game plan that happened today was me telling you guys what to do.
Let's remember this.
Justin is out here teaching you drive rush DP OS shit that nobody does.
Yeah, I got coached by Brian.
A little bit of credit would be nice.
No, no, no.
I wrote the documents you guys aren't reading.
I made the video.
I read the documents.
Doki, you did not read that document.
I did.
I actually did.
I made you a whole Modern Geek video guide.
You did not watch it.
I watched it, coach, just to let you know.
Oh, he did not make a video.
Oh, she didn't watch it.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to watch this fucking video right now.
I'm just saying, coach.
Gremlin is awake at 4 in the morning only.
I made a whole video because we could never meet up.
You made a video?
I saw the document.
No, Sha, you didn't see it?
No, I just saw the document.
I just saw the document.
Dude, he did a hand cam and everything, bro.
What?
You did a hand cam?
Okay, okay.
I'll watch the video tonight.
So, I'll join the finals.
I'll be even better.
I know you didn't watch it.
I knew from the beginning.
I was like, I made this.
But I didn't read.
I didn't read, though.
Read back the documents.
The documents.
Let the record show that there is a video, Your Honor.
10 minutes long, to be exact.
With a hand cam.
If I say, hey, Doki, in the beginning of it...
That shit is unlisted, alright?
It's okay.
I'm going to watch it.
I'm going to watch it before the finals.
And then it'll be like night and day.
Well, listen.
You didn't watch it and you're kicking ass.
So, maybe it's all for the best.
Whatever path we took to get here, it's working out.
Not wrong.
Dude, if she watches the video, all of a sudden she's doing like crazy-ass mix-ups.
No, that video is like really...
You're actually beyond that video.
I was extra baby mode.
I was like, this is a triangle.
This is a circle.
Like the blocks.
Sorry about it.
The triangle goes in the triangle hole.
Yeah, it was pretty much color and shape matching.
And that was about it.
So, we're good.
Nice.
Well, I think we're doing pretty good.
We clean house.
Holy shit.
Did any of them get any...
Just JB.
Like a game.
Oh yeah, I lost the first round.
Yeah, but you adapted.
You had a better game plan.
Just clean it up.
I didn't expect them to wake up DB every single time.
Yeah.
If I tell you someone's going to do something every time, just believe it.
Until it's really proven otherwise.
Because they are just going to do it.
Especially if they're like gold or whatever.
They will literally do it every time.
They can't help it.
Practice that stun combo.
Yeah, I'm doing it right now.
It was just the nerves.
I hit it every time in training.
I feel you.
I've dropped yesterday.
I don't know if you know SK with the stun combo, but you can walk forward first and then jump forward.
You have a lot of time before you have to do the jump in.
So don't rush it.
You can walk forward for one Mississippi and then jump.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, the stun lasts a while.
Yeah.
Where are we up next?
You have time to breathe.
We have Team Shine.
Oh, Team Shine.
So I'm playing...
I don't remember that one.
The Ed Blitz.
The Abundance of Ed Blitz.
Team Shine is...
Kana Yanagi.
So I'm playing against Bison again.
That was Bison, right?
Bright Shield and Fumi, I think, are the two Eds.
And then Infernasu, Akuma, and then Shine, which he'll play me with Ed or Kim.
Or Kim, yeah.
So...
Added an Eddy over there.
Yeah.
All his teammates wanted to copy him.
That's pretty cute, though.
Well, actually, they wanted to do the combo I'm doing, the level 2 combo.
Shine was like, oh, I didn't beat him, but I landed it on him.
He's like, you're wasting your minds.
Like, all they want to do now is...
Level 2?
Hey, it worked.
Poisoned the well, coach.
Good job.
Let's go.
Oh, Chad is snitching.
They said Fumi has a JP pocket.
So that would be against...
Me?
No.
Uh-oh.
I actually haven't had that hard of a time against JP, I'm not gonna lie.
Well, you played JP too, right, coach?
Yeah, I played a lot of JP.
But that is an annoying matchup, right?
It is, yeah.
It can be, but it also can go both ways.
Like, you can steamroll the fuck out of JP if they're not precise.
So, I wouldn't be too scared.
If you're getting zoned out real hard, we can take a breather and talk about it.
But I wouldn't put it off your game plan.
So, I know that you can amnesia regular grabs, but can you amnesia command grabs?
Yes, it beats everything besides projectiles.
In Season 1, it was unscaled and you got full combos.
That was great, I remember that.
It did more damage than a wake-up level 3.
If I did amnesia and you SPD'd me, I would just combo you for a full 60 seconds.
Yeah, you'd be just juggled over and over.
It was fun.
Good times.
You can still do that, but it's not worth it.
I'll be right back.
The combos now, the optimal combo if you wake up amnesia in the corner and they throw you, is just to back throw them.
You can still do all the cool combos, but the scaling is so bad that you literally do more damage just throwing them.
It's better for balance, but they made them definitely a little less saucy.
Are there anybody still playing JP competitively?
Most people dropped him.
They also nerfed his anti.
I think that's the main thing that sealed the deal.
His crouch fierce used to be god crouch fierce anti-air, and now it randomly loses.
And that's just too much.
And his burst damage isn't as good as other characters, so it's like they're all jumping at you, your anti-air is sometimes losing, and then you can't go as ham on them.
So for the most part, most top players dropped him.
He's still good though.
I'll be honest, I'm okay with this change, to be honest with you.
Yeah, he was not a fan favorite, huh?
Dude, people hated me.
Season 1 of Street Fighter VI, I got so many haters just for playing JP.
Yeah, people did not like JP, dude.
It did long-term damage to my brand.
Really?
Straight up, dude.
Street Fighter VI is hot, brand new, great, woo.
Content should take off, right?
I had a lot of people just fucking hate me.
Because you played JP?
Like, straight up.
This guy's never won a tournament in his life.
He's never played Street Fighter before, he's been spamming.
Damn!
I've earned the shit on my YouTube channel.
That's like crazy.
Damn, dude.
Yeah.
Dear God.
Good guys.
Uh, let's see here.
So are we ready for the EDs?
So...
I gotta worry about Akuma, that little bitch.
I hate him.
So for Doki, for Kanna...
Yeah?
My only notes were like, she just jumps all day.
Yeah, yeah.
And jumping forwards.
So DI randomly is not as good against her.
But, you know, down triangle or your jump air-to-air triangle would be good.
She literally like jumps backwards, bunny hops, and then jumps forward.
So you can like walk her down, and then when she jumps at you, do your anti-air.
Okay.
The person I'm fighting does flicker on every knockdown.
Is there anything I can do about that?
They do the charge one?
Yeah, yeah.
To like pull you in?
Yeah, so this is Bright Shield.
Okay, so...
Yeah, her anti-airs are mad good.
Don't jump at her.
But the charge flicker...
She likes to start by doing backdash in charge flicker.
So why don't you backdash and build your fireballs?
Okay.
In the beginning.
Yeah, because you can back away from her even further.
And then the flicker will whiff at max range.
You just...
1, 2, 3, build all your fireballs.
And then you know what to do.
Throw them out and drive her in.
But if she pulls you in...
She usually just throws you over and over.
Or you can backdash.
You can try to backdash away from it.
Throw attack or OD DP.
If I backdash, do I get to punish?
Not...
mid-screen, I don't believe.
But you can press a button first.
Okay.
What if I jump?
If you jump, she's going to modern DP you.
Oh yeah, good point.
Anyone else, like not modern, not her...
would say jump.
They'd fuck up the uppercut.
But she actually uppercutted every time.
It was kind of crazy.
She never stopped DI though.
I cheesed her so hard.
Yeah.
The other thing was she would do light kick, light kick.
With add that 1, 2.
And it has like the air wisp effect.
And then throw you after.
That's negative.
That's your turn.
With light move only or with medium move?
Negative 3.
You can press stand medium.
Let's go to the lobby real quick.
Wait, are you using Chun-Li or Juri?
I'm Juri gaming today.
Let's go.
I have the lobby open.
Join my lobby real quick.
Password 1, 2, 3, 4.
If you can search me up.
How do I input a password?
Search for my name.
You can search lobbies.
Or what's your name again?
I don't know how to search for a lobby.
I'm kind of on the same.
What's your in-game love, Reyna?
Yes, I love Reyna.
How do you spell that?
Oh, Reyna.
You don't know how to spell Reyna?
Not tech and play, eh?
R-E-I-N-A.
How could you?
R-E-I-N-A?
I said that.
Is it one word?
Yeah, one word.
It's one word, yeah.
Let me see if I can find you guys.
I can't believe this.
Juri!
The annoying thing about this is it's even hard to add people as friends.
I have you here.
I guess I can add you now as a friend.
A matchmaking error has occurred.
I backed out.
Oh, that would do it.
I followed you.
Oh fuck, I kicked you.
That's funny.
I think you can rejoin.
I'll re-invite.
My bad.
First you don't know how to spell Reina.
And then you kick me.
That's fucked.
I want a different team.
I'm out of here.
Damn, alright.
Maybe when I played Tekken for a week I didn't really like the cut of her jib.
You know what I'm saying?
And now you're...
It's over.
She's going to throw down.
She's not a very nice lady.
Justin is my real coach.
Fighting Rashid poisoned the well.
Oh my god.
This lady is not very nice.
She's proud of me.
I never said that, coach.
There's a couple things you should not do in this tournament.
And that's dis Reina.
Disrespect Reina in front of SK.
My bad.
Oh, I think we're up.
We got a second.
So just block this move.
So if I...
Just press stand medium punch or jab.
So the only options you have are like your jabs or stand medium.
Oh my god, Nephew lost his first game!
Hey!
The diaphone beat him.
He can bleed!
She would also do this.
He can bleed.
And he's legend 72 or whatever.
I didn't say any numbers.
Can you believe it?
It's also like really insulting to the players.
You've been saying it over and over.
Like to call Nephew online ranked number 72.
Like that is extremely insulting.
Let's go!
We found the nerve!
Let's poke it!
Yeah, that's just tilting me.
It's not them.
They don't hear a damn shit.
We're nerfing him!
I didn't say it!
I stopped.
So if I throw you...
I can't really do it there.
Maybe jump at me?
I'm gonna do it again.
Oh, I suck.
I lost my uppercuts.
I'm gonna do this.
I'm gonna pull you in.
They're getting ready to send invites.
Just jump at me.
Alright, back.
Sorry.
The other thing you can do is if it's that close, you can DI.
Okay.
So if I'm this close, DI.
This far, it's risky.
Got it.
But if it's like right here, you can try DI.
Whoa!
Invites out.
The thing is, if you block it, she likes to throw you after.
That's fine.
Okay, let's go join the invites.
I don't know how to leave.
Oh, you beat me up.
I already have a round.
Yeah, beat me up.
What?
Excuse me?
Oh, I just learned that like 20 minutes ago.
That was the combo.
That was the real dry rush combo.
That's the real one?
That's the real one.
That was for real.
Who do we join?
Is it Slamman?
Probably Slamman.
Online.
What the fuck?
What?
I posted first.
On my screen.
I see you first too, Doki.
Oh, it's Tails.
Sorry, it's Tails.
Collusion for us.
Save by ping.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
This side swapping business.
This is... yeah.
SageM definitely poisoned your guys' brains by doing Tekken first.
Everyone's a Tekken player in here.
Right.
Yeah, for all of us playing Tekken.
Yeah, I can tell.
It's obvious.
It's so hard.
It's like the moves...
The button swap.
It's weird.
My fingers aren't used to that.
To the swapping.
Yeah, I get you.
I'm teasing.
It makes sense.
I can't handle it.
Let's go, Doki.
Jumping.
I don't understand why she hasn't...
Yeah, she's just gonna walk back and randomly jump.
Brace yourself.
I'm on the other side.
This is bad.
Nice.
Alright, we're good.
Let's get clean.
Let's game.
Doki's a menace, dude.
What?
She's a menace, bro.
It's all here.
Just triangle.
Okay.
Yeah!
Condition.
She's starting to...
She's predicting that now.
Oh, okay.
She's mashing out a combo.
It was tickle.
You're good.
Yeah.
Did level 3, but do you care?
No, not really.
Not at all.
No.
Who cares, dude?
Just get in there.
Oh, that's alright.
Good idea.
But she jumps again.
She just does the same thing over and over.
You know what to do.
Okay.
Oh, wait a minute.
I got my own scissor kick, amigo.
Oh.
Unlucky.
Yeah, we just block it out.
You gotta wait for her to jump and down triangle.
Oh, my God.
Yo.
Unlucky.
Okay.
Did she jump?
Oh, my God.
Oh, you got it.
Nice.
Dude, watching Doki play is way better than anything on Disney Plus right now.
This kid is crazy.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
This is great.
That was awesome.
Good job.
The only thing is the jump triangles.
If you can do a down triangle, that'll get her every time.
But if not, it's all good.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It doesn't even matter.
Unlucky.
I pressed the wrong button reflexively.
Nice defense.
That was so good.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Great blocks.
Nice.
Get in there.
Press triangle.
Yeah.
After you land the command grab, just don't even do nothing.
She wakes up DI there every time.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't even realize that.
Burned out.
Yeah.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
If you land a triangle, just don't attack her after.
That's the only thing.
All right.
Everything else is perfect.
Yeah, that's fine.
What do I do here?
You just block.
You know, she's gonna just jump at you randomly.
Just block it out a little bit.
Okay.
Okay, you're good.
Exactly.
See?
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
Nice.
Ah, I need to remember to...
See, she does that every time.
Yeah.
Every time you knock her down, she's gonna wake up with that.
So, when we knock her down...
Let's do it back.
My loyal fans!
Okay, so she's probably gonna wake up with the DI again.
Yeah.
So you can walk up and jump over her or walk up and block.
But don't do a big move.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Wait, is this death?
No.
I get it.
Yeah!
Let's go, Doki!
Let's go!
Yeah!
I'm gold!
I'm a gold player!
I'm a gold player.
I don't need a rank.
Yeah, just don't even worry about rank, dude.
I don't need rank.
It hurts them even more to lose to a lower-ranked player.
Exact mind games!
Yes!
Just be a new challenger.
Just make a new account.
Make a new account!
You'll look like a smurf if you're on there.
I'll buy a new game.
Awesome time.
I wonder what rank number you are, Doki.
I'm rank 119.
Damn.
That's up there, Doki.
Looks like his name is Med with that M there.
Med, let's go!
You know the game plan.
Let's go.
Yep, perfect.
Exactly, yep.
Nice.
Oh, yes!
Nice!
Sick!
That's alright.
Oh, yay!
My poor heart!
That's fucking gold!
She cheated against Chun-Li, not you!
There you go, that's good.
The lab work, hell yes.
Oops.
It's all good.
That was good by her.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, just save your meter a little bit.
Like, just don't do anything.
That's fine.
We'll survive.
Oh, goodbye cube.
It's alright.
You're alive, but you're in a bad situation.
You're in a bad spot.
But they spent the super early, so you're good.
The comeback is real!
Nice.
Good job backing out of the range.
If that happens again, just backdash and build your fireballs.
And you're good.
Okay.
Yeah, she's giving you space.
When she gives you all that space, just build a fireball.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah!
We can hit that on the right side every time, huh?
Yup.
That feels like a callout.
Oh.
I'm slow.
Oh, she baited it.
Oh my goodness.
That's okay.
You blocked it though.
So let's just let her rock a little.
Nice!
Exactly.
Oh, what the hell.
Don't use that sweep anymore.
You can't DI cancel it.
Yeah, don't use sweep.
Okay, back up.
You can back up, and then...
Nice.
That's a good block.
Oh, that was a good parry.
Oh, that's close!
That's close.
It's fine.
When you're approaching, you're gonna back up, you're gonna throw the fireball, and when she gives you space, just keep building fireball over and over and throwing it, and when you dry brush, you dry brush mediums.
You're doing the big buttons, she's mashing DI.
Do small buttons, like mediums.
Yup, there you go!
And then she mashes on wake up every time.
And then she does DI.
So just after, just let her wake up, and let her do DI.
And then just counter DI.
And you know what to do after that.
See?
Yeah, she's just doing DI over and over.
Nice!
She's gonna do DI.
I'm just slow.
That's cool.
Let's just let her do DI and try to bait it.
Okay, I will counter every single one.
I believe!
When you're up close to her, don't press buttons.
Just don't press buttons when you're close to her.
She's just mashing and then doing DI.
Okay, just block.
Don't do that.
Just block.
There you go.
Yup.
Nice.
Yes!
Nice!
Oh, that's insane!
That shit was insane!
Good control.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
That's what I'm talking about!
Super?
Oh no, that's okay.
And now just back up.
Just back up.
She's gonna throw you.
Oh, nice throw!
You get one button on offense.
And then you gotta stop and she's gonna DI.
Download complete!
Yeah, no meter spent.
Lovely.
Throw your fireball.
And then that shields you.
So you can drive her behind it.
She's gonna DI.
Yeah, don't press.
Just let her jab, jab, jab.
Yeah, that's fine.
Okay, no problem.
Composure.
You have your super too.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, you can't do it out of that one move.
Oh, it's alright, it's alright.
Good try, SK.
Good try, good try.
It was way better than last time.
That's for sure.
You were adapting real good.
Yeah.
Good try.
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
Just don't do anything when you're next to her.
No, I want to do things.
I want to do things.
Yeah.
I didn't pay $70 for all the moves I was doing.
Except the last one.
I was just too slow.
This kind of player, they don't...
Oh boy, they're actually using JP.
Oh, they're going for the JP.
Oh, they are!
Have they been training JP a lot?
I haven't, so...
I mean, they're Diamond 4, so...
Yeah, they're pretty good.
That's true.
I mean, you know about his command grab, right, Brawl?
Yes.
Yeah, that's the only thing.
Like, if you're pairing too much, you might try to command grab.
So, just do what you got to do.
And just be wary if he starts using that move a lot.
And you're good.
Fast forward into command grab.
I love this move.
Oh.
Oh, nice!
There we go.
Oh, he's scared.
She's scared, she's scared.
Good blocks.
Alright, you're good.
The patience.
Oh, yeah!
Yee-haw!
Nice.
Even when she counter-picked.
Oh,
nice.
Oh, that was a good grab.
That does so much damage.
Yeah, the EX-1 is a lot.
Oh, the overhead.
No.
Just parry.
Bro, what the fuck?
He just fills the screen with shit.
Okay.
Oh, wow, she got those.
Oh, yeah, she definitely got those.
Whoa.
She adapted so fast.
Which is really hard for Gief to get in.
Yeah.
You have to be real patient.
Oh.
Alright, just get...
There you go.
No more nose.
And now we go in.
Yeah!
Party time.
Just try not to whiff knee because they'll jump out.
Nice!
Oh, my God.
Get them.
One more and you get level three.
Nice.
You're right about the knee.
You're right, you're right.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Just parry, just parry, just parry.
I said parry.
You got this, man.
You got this, amigo.
Composure.
Damn.
Okay.
When she does level two, just hold parry.
Just hold parry.
It's a high-low mix.
You can't block it.
And then when you parry a projectile, you can try threatening parry, hold parry, then dry brush in.
And then she's just jumping when you're close.
You got to larry it.
Okay.
Nice.
Get them.
Don't do need SPD.
Don't do none of that.
She's just a jumper.
Just everything, just buttons and lock her down until you're really confident about the SPD.
Yeah.
Try to jump out of the corner.
Doesn't matter.
Jesus.
So much damage.
So you can try dry rushing in if she does...
Oh, no.
That was an accident.
That's so obnoxious.
Yeah.
You see why Bryan lost a little bit of reputation.
Now I know why people hated him.
Yeah.
Watching this makes me angry.
After you parry a fireball, dry brush at them.
She's doing fireball, then setting the portal up above your head.
So if you're at a distance and you absorb a fireball, then she does the portal, you dry brush in.
If you don't dry brush in, you're never going to threaten anything.
Okay.
There you go.
You could have let that go all the way.
Just let the dry brush rock and get closer.
Nice.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Okay, conserve your meter.
There you go.
Free combo.
Nice.
Conserve your meter still.
She's just a jumper, man.
She just jumps.
Okay.
Jesus.
Okay, you're good.
Now you're exactly that.
Exactly that.
She throws fireball, then does portal.
If she does that, you can just dry brush all the way fullscreen and attack.
Nice.
Remember, she just likes to jump on Oki.
That's what she wants to do.
Yeah.
Okay, that's cool.
Exactly.
Yep, she's going to still try to jump or do random cane swing.
Oh, nice.
What was that?
See, she's still jumping.
It was a counter.
Hold parry, hold parry.
Just hold parry.
There you go.
Let's go!
Nice!
Now you can threaten dry brush.
Let's go!
Whoa, whoa!
I quit!
The adaptation!
That's going to be your best jump.
We're in this.
Hold parry, hold parry.
When the portals are about to pop above your head, you can parry.
Okay, you're good.
Back in the corner you go, Migo.
You know, buttons, pressure.
I have to respect her a little more.
Yeah, she's adapting to me.
Yeah, there you go.
Nice, nice.
So parry.
Yeah, when the portals are about to pop.
Yeah, good dry brush.
Nice!
Okay, just don't let her jump out.
Yeah, just keep it solid.
Keep her in there.
Don't whip a knee.
Just keep her caged.
I see.
Yeah, you got to do this the old-fashioned way.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think this is where things get really bad.
So this is why don't use your defensive options with meter.
Consider your meter.
You need it for when you're zoned out.
Nice.
Okay.
There you go.
Yeah, exactly.
She just wants to jump out or do random DI.
Nice!
There you go, get him!
So just be aware.
Told you!
That's what you need, control.
Keep them caged in the corner.
Don't need to go for SPD over and over.
Nice!
Let's fucking go.
Get that damage, amigo.
Oh!
Okay.
Displace all defense.
Yes.
She has no two.
It's all right.
Just block, just block.
Yeah, you're good.
Yeah, she's just gonna try to jump over and over.
Nice!
Now you can stun her.
Drive rush, crash medium.
Let's go, baby!
Let's go!
Bro, bro, baby!
Nice adaptation!
Adaptation!
Dude, you're playing disgusting, dude.
On the fly, dude.
I had no idea.
I had no idea what to do in game one.
Learn the matchup.
You learned the matchup on the fly.
That's so impressive.
You have no idea.
Yeah!
That's the master player right there!
Thank you for listening.
Dude, you said stun her, but I almost did, but I'm like, no, she's gonna level three.
That's fine, that's fine.
You have better Oki reads than me.
The only thing I know is she's jumping.
And you're not antering.
That's the only thing.
You're the grappler player.
I started to, thank God.
All right, here we go.
My heart, I hate the slam.
Yeah, dude.
I agree.
So, you're not the tiebreaker anymore.
It's easier.
That is a little better, yes.
The tiebreaker was unreal.
Ugh.
And you finally, you parried level two.
Thank God.
Oh my God.
That shit's literally a high-low, left-right, like you have to parry.
Okay.
Let's go, go.
Oh.
Nice jump out.
Let's go.
That's fine.
It's all good.
He's doing that medium kick to overhead turret combo a lot.
It's just kind of a gimmick.
So, just don't worry about it.
Yeah.
Nice.
Nice tech.
Yeah.
Time to play, let's go.
I love when he starts grabbing.
I've heard grabs are so nice.
Yeah.
Typical Akuma bullshit.
Fireball.
He's low in drive meter.
Yeah, that's cool.
Nice.
Let's go.
That was a good jump.
Nice.
Nice prediction.
Stun him immediately after this.
Stun him.
Yes, sir.
Nice.
Good drop.
Nice K.O.
Let's go.
Yeah,
every time he does medium kick, he's just going to overhead.
There's so many blocking.
This is a heavy defense game.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, you saw my match.
Like, what the fuck?
It's a Roy practice for you.
Nice.
Yep.
That's fine.
Oh, yes.
He's almost burnt, too.
What?
That's spaghetti.
Don't worry about it.
You got lucky.
Nice break.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, that's close.
When he demon flips and he comes down with the chop, he's plus there.
So you keep getting hit and then he just goes into overhead.
So just chill for a second.
Don't hit rematch.
Oh, sorry.
And so just throw him into dry brush medium, dude.
Like, you're respecting him too much.
This guy is not going to fucking react.
You can do stabby hands also to get over his zoning.
He's not going to deal with any of that shit.
Like, you're better than him.
Just rush him down.
That's fucking right.
You're better.
Rank up the offense.
You know what to do.
Yes, sir.
Let's go.
That was just random.
Don't worry about it.
He got a lot out of that bullshit, though.
Nice.
Nice interruption.
Punish.
Don't be scared to rush him down, man.
After throw, do dry brush medium, dry brush heavy, and do stabby hands if it's zoning too much.
This guy is not going to deal with it.
Holy shit.
I've never seen that move before.
That's the stabby hands.
Look how much damage this does.
Get into your flow, bro.
He's not going to know what to do.
He's so confused.
I'm confused, too.
I'm not going to lie.
I was like, wait.
I've never seen that.
Nice, sir.
There you go.
He's dead.
Let's go.
He's 100% dead.
He's not going to know what to do.
Just rush him down your normal game.
Just don't play slow.
If it's too slow, stabby hands.
Got you.
Let's go, man.
No respect.
One more.
Now he's scared.
He's throwing so many.
Okay.
Good.
It's good that he punished that.
Oh, shit.
Damn.
Jeez.
Nice escape.
Nice.
What did he do there?
Dive kick.
Oh, you're both burned out.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice back throw.
Yep.
He's not going to know what to do.
That's fine.
Oh.
Yeah.
If he blocks, he blocks low.
So, dry rush medium so you can throw him again.
Or dry rush overhead.
Got you.
Oh.
Nice defense.
Nice.
Nice jump out.
Yes, sir.
So, he's probably going to mash super.
Yep.
Oh, nice move.
Oh, nice punish.
Yes.
Good jump.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Exactly.
Let's go.
What a read on that coat.
Yeah.
Man, these matches are more intense than last...
the first day.
Yes, sir.
You know the combos.
We got the lead.
Mixing.
Mixing his ass.
He's confused.
Nice attack.
Yes, sir.
He's just on... Oh.
That's fine.
He's even messing up his mash.
He's tilt.
He's almost burnt, so don't worry about it.
I didn't miss it.
Yeah.
So close.
That was such a wonky anti-air.
It was all into the cross-up at the end.
Yeah.
It was just one interaction.
Could have gone either way, I think.
Yeah.
He was doing a bunch of random silly demon flip shenanigans.
And Akuma's so awkward.
You try to anti-air, but his dive kick stalls him.
I hope they butcher this character.
I'm not even gonna lie.
I hope they fucking gut him.
Capcom, you're watching this?
His fireballs are so annoying.
Next patch, nerfed Aki.
Alright.
God, I hope not.
They just barely buffed.
She was so bad.
Alright, coach.
Good luck.
You got this, coach.
Oh, is Shine here, actually?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Did he leave already?
Well, he might be in his match for the other thing, so I guess we have to see.
It says he's muted.
He's here.
DQ.
If the teacher doesn't arrive in 15 minutes, then it's...
We can legally leave the class.
He's here.
I don't know what he's doing.
He got DQ'd on the last round.
He is here, though.
It's not like he's in the Capcom thing.
Maybe he's just watching the other, like, watching the players from the other tournament.
Oh, well, he's gotta get going here.
I can't imagine him not coaching his master rank player.
DQ.
He's coming.
Just kidding.
Oh, okay.
You just switched to Kim.
Okay.
That's the way he played last time, though.
I don't even remember.
It was kind of close last time.
It was very close, yeah.
Okay, cool.
Let's go.
Alright, let's do this.
Good luck, coach.
Let's go.
Oh,
that's so cheap.
Kimberly's just oppressive as hell.
Yeah, she's very offensive.
I like Kimberly's default costume more than this one.
Really?
Yeah, I think your default costume's cute.
I like the baggy pants one.
My bad.
Go, Brian.
Go.
Let's go, coach.
That was a good break, man.
Just straight up nooch.
Oh, that's a nice carry.
Let's go to the other side, and they're burnt out soon.
Their end players never did this before.
Oh, I think they're dead.
He's dead.
Yeah.
Oh, nice!
Oh, we're crossing into the Z-axis with this one, boys.
Let's go.
That was a Tekken 7 wall carry.
Uh-oh.
They kicked you out?
Oh, they kicked me out?
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Because I had a conversation, so I got kicked out.
Violated the code of conduct.
It's okay.
I swear we won't have conversations anymore.
Oh, man.
Oh, he baited the anti-air.
Yeah.
That's the hard part.
Oh, for having Akuma and Kim just like those stop momentum type of air moves.
I hate them.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, pressure time.
And chip.
Oh, nice!
Oh, you can turn into Rashid like that.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Hey, that's so cool.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, nice blocks.
Nice interrupt!
Let's go, coach!
Oh, go, coach!
Yes!
Slam dunk.
Let's fucking go!
Hell, yeah.
Look at that pretty boy.
Oh, my God.
That was so cool.
Oh, man.
Nice.
One more, coach.
One more just like that.
Dude, he's so good.
Did you guys see the last set, too?
That was crazy.
All right.
No conversation.
No conversations or you get kicked out by the Capcoms.
Here we go.
That was a good call.
Nice.
Nice mash.
Oh, nice.
Okay, nice DP.
Oh, out of the air, Amiga.
Good block.
That's one of the things with Kimberly.
She can put you back in the corner.
Here we go.
Oh, nice.
Oh, nice counter.
Back in the corner, Amiga.
Back in the corner, you go.
It's fucking go.
No punish.
Okay, nice.
They're just throwing each other in the corner.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
And still.
Oh.
Should have taught your end players this.
Here we go.
Oh, the shimmy.
Oh, my God.
He's disgusting.
Nice blocks.
Back in here.
Get over here.
Turn into Scorpion.
Oh, the mash.
God, he's so oppressive.
Uh-oh.
That was good.
Yeah, he had to.
He had to.
He saw him.
He saw him charging.
He was too tired of the corner.
Oh, that was a good jump for me.
Grambled eggs.
Oh, that's so nasty.
What the fuck?
And to another blender mix-up.
Ay, ay, ay.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
I hate characters like this, dude.
Why can't they do that?
Blender characters, dude.
Fine.
I don't even know what just happened.
Neutral happened, Doki.
Neutral.
That's also annoying.
He baits out the anti-air.
Yeah.
Alright, it's not over.
Still in there.
She has her power-up, and that's the only thing.
Oh, now he's counting.
Yeah.
He baited.
Good try.
Nice try.
We adapt.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
Easy.
I believe.
Woo!
Conversion!
Oh my god.
Oh, that was crazy.
Oh.
The spacing, though, is crazy.
Let's go!
Watch your toes, amigo!
Nice.
A meter, though.
Yeah.
Take a easy.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Nice.
Get back in the corner.
Let's go!
Get in there, coach!
Yeah!
Oh, this is so intense.
Yeah.
Coach's match is so scary.
I know.
Yeah, I'm feeling it for him.
Let's go!
Nice!
This is neutral.
It's okay.
Everybody's just...
Oh, nice
shot!
That shot was insane!
It's gonna be a lot of damage, but not death.
Oh, that combo was sick.
Oh, this fucking combo!
Oh!
Did you have one?
For the fans!
Give me the damn points!
Give me them points!
That's right!
Oh my god!
Let's go.
GG's.
Dude, hold on.
We gotta do this.
We gotta... GG's.
Oh!
Hold on.
I'm not done yet.
Where are you?
What are you typing?
GG's smile.
Let's go, baby!
Oh my god.
You guys gotta understand.
Shine has been like my tournament demon for like seven years.
Oh, has he?
Seven years?
I have maybe like three set wins out of like 30.
Oh!
Wow!
We got four now, man!
We have to end up with a four!
Oh my god.
Let's go.
That's insane.
Dude, that's...
The neutral jump into the overhead punch and then the jump into the low.
No, empty jump low was...
That was the icing on top, dude.
That was sick.
4-26, baby!
We're 4-26!
We're cooking.
He's gonna think about that in his tournament now.
I feel bad.
Shine's my boy.
We're good friends.
I don't gotta blame him for Cap'Em Cup.
I want him to cook there, just not here.
That's fucking tough.
We actually don't have a break because Lillipichu's internet exploded, so we're doing this one next.
We're going next.
Oh, okay.
So we're saving Lill...
So Doki's match, we're saving from last.
Oh, okay.
What's going on?
No, look at stage three.
They just tagged us.
Group B first.
We're towards the end.
For Lillipichu's internet exploded.
So we're going to do Group B.
So I don't have to play yet.
Doki will play later.
Me and you need to test something real quick.
Do they have trainee spots open in there?
I don't think they...
Did they send out the invites?
I'm checking.
I only have Slam Man, which is the...
I got an invite from Claire.
Okay.
Okay, so Doki, meet me in the training thing real quick.
Meet me in the field.
I only have Slam Man's invite.
Oh, for my game, I have a request.
Oh?
Everyone can talk and all this is good, but for coaching, I only want to know if I'm like getting scammed by something.
Like if I'm not punishing a move that is punishable, or if like when Skar was fighting me, he was doing two heavy punches into the grab, but you can just jump it, and I thought it was guaranteed.
Like that kind of thing.
Okay, I'll shut up.
No, no.
No, that's good.
Tell me to shut up, especially if I don't shut up and I need me to shut up.
Please tell me to shut up.
I totally understand.
I'm in the...
It's just like extra mental attack when there's like backseat and I think about what I want to do.
I'll make sure to be quiet.
Which one is this one?
This is team who?
Oh, Nephew.
But I'll also ask SK, please then don't hit rematch.
Okay.
For everybody, we don't have to hit rematch.
You can go back to lobby.
I will not do that.
I can fake Chun-Li swap too, to get in their heads.
Yeah, because if there's something obvious that can help you, we need a little bit of time to just say it, right?
Okay, got it.
Alright.
I'm in training room four.
Okay, I'm heading over there.
I got shopper backseating, true.
Shopper backseating.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got banned.
Okay, so the move you gotta look out for, Doki, is this move.
Yeah.
So this is what gives her the soar.
So in the top right by my name, it shows a number, and then every time I do this move, it burns one of those resources.
The thing is, this is plus.
Okay.
So if she's able to back up, she wants to do this and build up.
So in the beginning, you can rush her down and do DI, like get closer in the beginning so that she doesn't build this up.
Yeah, but once she has this, what's gonna happen is this is gonna come out out of nowhere.
Yeah.
So when you block this, how does she do command grab?
Let me see, hold on a second.
Yeah, she can do a command grab after that spinny spin.
I can't grab it back.
I want us to start.
I'm scared.
No, just play your game.
It's okay.
You got it, SK.
Should I wait for your training thing or do I just go?
I can go.
Wait one second.
We'll stop for one second.
So yeah, if you block this, just jump.
If you block the one that's enhanced with wind, because I'm gonna try to do a command grab after.
Okay.
Yeah, so if you block the fancy one, block, jump I mean, sorry.
Now if you block, when she doesn't have one, it's gonna look way less cool.
Yeah.
That one you can press your squares or whatever.
Or a triangle, whatever.
These are not very good.
But the one where it's super, all the wind and everything, she's gonna back up and do this and just fly at you, you need to jump after.
She's gonna try to grab you after.
Alright.
We leave.
I'm going.
We watch now.
We'll watch and cheer calmly.
Yeah!
Okay.
Manon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Manon, Manon.
You got it.
You lab for this.
Manon.
Is she French?
Yes.
Yeah, Scar only plays French characters.
Yeah.
He's so French.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, dude.
Let's go.
Ouch.
Okay, I need to jump so much more.
Nice.
I'm just gonna hold up.
Yeah?
Mhm.
And just get a big punish when she whips.
Nice.
Beautiful.
That's alright.
There you go.
Got him.
Nice.
Alright.
Very nice.
Oh, rush him down.
Burn him out.
Nice!
He's burnt.
Let's go.
Get him!
Let's go!
Very clean.
Take that, Scarra.
Oh, yeah.
Dude, get a little toxic with it.
I love it.
Yeah!
He doesn't know what to do when you're in the air.
Woo!
Oh, what a grab!
What the fuck?
Reset his ass.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh, my god.
Just rush him down.
Let's go, SK.
That's insane!
Let's go.
Play your game.
Go.
What a game.
My dog is getting excited, too.
Oh, no.
My dog's getting hyped.
Oh, it must be a good match, then.
He's enjoying it.
Oh, he's getting jump-happy now.
Oh, I'm old.
That's alright.
Alright, he's older.
I'm old.
Skarra's, like, 49.
Yeah!
What?
So, he just always command grabs there, SK.
Okay.
So, too heavy punch, if you get just pulled up, straight up.
He always command grabs there every single time.
And then you can do those splits as you land, those heavy kicks.
Nice anti-air!
God damn!
Nice!
Let's go!
Holy shit, look at you go!
Oh, I was holding...
I was holding jump there.
Was that one real?
That's a combo, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Nice!
Burn her out!
Nice.
Let's go!
Burn her out!
That's okay, block her!
Oh, nice jump!
That's a grab.
Oh, okay.
Just chill.
What do I do to get out of this?
Yeah, you have to... the only way out of that...
You could have leveled three.
Yeah.
Level three or level one.
Spamming that, you have to do super, and you have to do it right away.
So it's very tough.
Yeah.
So just try to not burn yourself out.
Okay, I see you.
Okay, he's doing the hits instead of command grabbing you right now.
There you go.
Yeah.
Nice!
Nice combo!
Oh, almost had it.
Good idea, good idea.
Nice jump out.
Holy shit, that was insane!
One more time.
Woo!
Oh my god!
You're so sick with it!
You're so sick with it, SK!
I can't believe this.
He's mortal!
He's insane!
Very clean.
Make him bleed!
Oh, where's my health?
That's called grabbing.
Remember, he always command grabs there.
You can just DP also.
That beats everything.
He does two slaps and he presses something.
Just always DP there.
He never blocks there.
He's always doing something.
Let's do this.
Woo!
That was clean!
That was good.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Oh nice!
Nice!
Oh, I missed him with my super.
Fine.
No!
Oh, sorry.
It was close.
It was a close match.
He had that level three.
Oh, that would have turned it around.
That was a good try though.
Good try.
You had a good game plan.
It's just like when you went in with the drive rush, you would press the medium too early.
Like it's just, you know, experience.
You whiff the medium and then the second medium would come out and he would hit you or DI you.
Oh, okay.
I was trying to press it earlier because he was like hitting me out of it.
Dude, SK.
Sunday, you're going to be a beast.
Yeah, yeah.
You're going to give them a false sense of security and you're going to beat the shit out of them.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah, your strategy is better.
It's just tightening up the timing.
I see this.
Go, go, go!
Hey, hey!
Oh, nice grab!
Holy shit, his HP's gone.
Yeah, right?
It's gone.
Dissipated.
That was fast.
It took like five seconds.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
Ooh, I like that.
Oh.
I thought you were not fast, dude.
That's fine.
Has he got these?
Interesting combo, yeah.
Oh, he don't have the rhythm.
Nah, he don't got this.
That's hard, too, to be honest.
Nice.
Ooh, that was unlucky.
It's all good.
You can turn this around.
Yeah.
He'll be so sick, too.
Oh, he's so scared.
That was unlucky with Elaria.
Yeah, that was unlucky.
Just don't worry about it.
He's trying to walk away from you.
Yeah.
So just, you know, jump towards him and use your jump medium kick and stuff like that.
See?
Yeah.
I don't know if he's going to jump but the ball is going to be on his head anyway.
Oh, that was a good one.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
You're in.
You're inside.
You're in his head.
Oh!
Nice grab!
Here we go.
Oh, come on.
That prediction is crazy.
That's right, he tried, he tried, he tried.
Oh my gosh!
One more, he might super...
Yeah.
Ooh, I like it.
Woo!
Nice!
He's from the tip!
Let's go.
Nice!
Woo!
I can't believe he had time.
So that's a super fast sweep.
He has a unique sweep.
But you can't punish it.
Oh yeah!
Oh nice punish, he knows about it.
Yeah, just...
Don't need the gimmicks.
Yeah, just secure the win.
Ooh, BJ's fun.
Hey, hey, hey.
Okay.
No worries, no worries.
Oh, nice!
Oh, so close!
Just need a little pixel.
That was good.
Nice parry though.
Damn it.
Fine, I'll stop DIing.
Yeah.
You can DI, but not like, defensively up close.
Like, you're gonna DI from further away.
Mhm.
He's gonna be trying to press bigger buttons, not up close.
Got it.
Do you have level 3?
You got level 3, just in case things fail.
Yeah, beat him.
You got level 2 also.
Nice.
Yep, good patience.
Oh, nice!
Nice.
He's cornered.
Well, that's too far.
Is it?
That was close.
Alright, you got one more game.
Yeah, the knee stuff is not gonna work on him at all.
He's always out of that range.
He's always walking away, always jumping.
Don't work on people who are constantly out of your range.
Okay.
There you go.
Nice!
Let's get in there.
Oh, he's disoriented!
That was close.
Nice!
Oh, nice combo!
Let's go, baby!
The call-out, dude!
The call-out.
Nice!
That's good.
Oh yeah, I can make him pay.
That's a good punish.
That's a good finish.
Uh-oh.
I see the vision.
Okay.
Yeah, just conserve your meter.
Yeah, good play.
Come on!
Baby!
Yeah!
Come on!
Oh my god!
You're disgusting, bro!
You're disgusting, brother!
My loyal fans!
Let's go!
You just traumatized them.
Good patience, dude.
That was incredible.
That was sick!
That's legit what you do.
If there's dry brush cancels, you buffer level 3 like that.
That's the thing to do.
What's level 3?
Is it 720 in this game still?
Yes.
Oh, you turned that shit hard.
That was crazy fast.
Let's go, dude.
See, I'm so good with the tournament pressure, bro.
Period.
End it there, bro.
I'm so good.
You're just so used to it.
Let's go.
Alright, let's see this.
Alrighty.
It's so nerve-wracking, though.
It really is.
You're chasing a feeling.
You can win.
I believe, I believe.
Who is he playing now?
Huntress.
Huntress is in training right now.
I got notes.
Let's see.
Dude, I just realized I think Zangief is the most Tekken character in his entire roster.
Yeah.
He's the only one that has to dry brush to gain space just like a Tekken game.
And his damage is insane, too.
From just, like, four hits.
Yeah, but you have to find them, though.
Yeah.
What is Huntress Tekken right now?
Another DQ.
Let's go.
She wants coin flip.
I can just give it up.
I don't care, really.
Damn, you can do either side?
Oh, yeah.
That's cheating.
You should probably coin flip just so she can get to player two, though.
Oh, no, you should.
Yeah, you should have.
On Sunday, we should do that.
On Sunday, we should do that, for sure.
It really does not matter.
At least we have to be the heel.
We did the training.
It doesn't matter.
We don't need any bullshit advantages.
No, but we're the heel of the tournament.
There's nothing more heel than just being fucking better.
But it's like just salt on the wound.
You gotta win first to do that.
Let's get the W.
Oh, what?
Nice jump out.
Nice.
Let's go, man.
Yeah, at first knockout, she always does that.
She draws it, though.
You're good.
Oh, nice.
She's buffering super, so don't throw a fireball.
What the fuck?
Nice.
Yeah, just don't throw a fireball.
Just fucking goomba stomp.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Yeah!
That shit's insane!
Let's go.
Nice defense.
That's totally fine.
She's so low on meter now.
Nice.
Yes, sir.
Oh, another grab!
Yeah.
Holy shit!
Nice.
Oh, beautiful.
She's at level three.
Oh, shit, yeah.
You forced her to burn it.
And now you have your super in case she does DI.
Yeah, she has no super, so you can throw fireballs.
Don't worry about this, aren't you?
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
Don't wanna go.
Nice.
Oh, beautiful.
Oh, nice grab!
Mine!
Level three.
Yeah, poison her!
Oh my god.
She fed it all on that.
Yeah, what a gamble.
Fine.
Oh, what the fuck was that?
Oh, wow.
Oh, nice grab!
Just be careful about her level two.
Nice!
Let's go!
One thing, just remember, drive rush medium punch after throws, too.
They're all blocking down back or overhead.
And if you do drive rush medium punch, you can easily get another throw without walking and all that.
So it's the only thing that can tighten up your pressure a little bit.
Oh, team of grapplers.
Yeah, and that goes straight into the coward crouch after that.
Nice challenge.
Oh!
A little pokey poke.
Yeah!
Nice!
Today is so...
It's so intense.
Hey, conserve your meter after this.
Yeah, just don't drive rush for a little while.
What the fuck?
Oh, wow.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Nice!
You're back!
Oh!
What the fuck!
What are you doing?
I knew it!
I knew it had something in my heart, dude!
Let's go!
You are crazy!
I don't even know what happened!
This guy...
I can't believe it.
It just looked sick, though!
I...
Dude.
Oh, she has can-cans.
Nice.
Getting cheeky with it.
She's flustered.
Oh my god.
You're in her head!
Ko, you're in her head!
Oh my god.
Oh!
It's the throw loop!
Let's go!
I can't believe you!
Oh my god.
Let's go, baby!
You throw looped a master plan!
That's fucking insane!
That's actually so toxic.
Oh my... That's so toxic.
I'm team grappler, dude.
I got brawl pro and doki.
I got a grapple, dude.
That's what I'm saying, dude.
Get grappled!
You are crazy.
I should've converted that counter hit like forward heavy kick, but...
I'll be right back.
Damn.
You mind broke her.
That shit's gonna haunt her.
She's so good.
I've been dreading that matchup so much.
I'm like, ah shit.
Because I raided her and she's like analyzing my matches.
I'm like, oh shit.
That's fucked.
I was definitely afraid of her matchups.
That's intense, yeah.
Alright, so is Lily ready?
Am I playing Lily or is it coach match?
I think she's still downloading.
Wait, downloading what?
I think she had to reinstall or something.
I think.
Okay.
Dude, the less points we can give Team Nephew, the better.
Alright?
I mean, we actually are catching up to Team Nephew.
Huh?
We're catching up to Nephew's team.
Are we?
We're currently tied with Shine's team.
We both have 79 points and Nephew has 89 points.
Oh wow, wow.
Yeah.
So we're catching up.
Oh wow, wow.
Yeah.
So we're catching up.
Nice.
But Shine's team played more games.
Oh, okay.
Sweet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see here.
Yeah, no.
I don't know why, but I had this weird feeling that she was going to super there.
Bro, but even...
That was sick though.
But still, the grabs.
That was so funny.
And the thing is, she doesn't even have a good throw loop.
Her throw loop is not as easy as like Jury's or...
Oh, any other character.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, apparently I hit my zone minutes on my Fitbit.
Let's go.
That's enough exercising for the year.
Yeah, my watch is like, hey, slow down, dude.
I just started her Joker arc.
I didn't mean to start her Joker arc.
I just want to play video games.
Now she's only going to train for you.
Oh, there's an outage in her area.
Oh, so she has to download...
She has to go somewhere else to download.
Possibly, yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
Or DQ.
I'm going in, guys.
Alright, get in there, brother.
This is going to be probably the hardest match of the day, so let's do this.
Ain't no pressure.
You got this, amigo.
Oops.
SK's trying to fight.
She's trying to throw hands.
He's like, me next, me next.
That match with Skara left her hungry.
Oh, yes.
That was definitely winnable, yeah.
He just did the command throw.
All of your matches that you've lost are 100% winnable.
Just one more.
Couple more days of training.
Oh my god.
You're going to be nasty.
Alright, coach has to lock in.
Alright, lock in, coach.
No conversations, I guess.
I'm going to use the backdoor.
Nice.
Yeah, that was good.
Nice try, nice try.
Perfect parry.
Get him.
Oh, and the optimal punish for meter damage.
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah.
Nice anti-air.
Woo, and throw up that.
Nice.
Does it kill?
Yes.
No, yeah, that's definitely going to kill.
Alright.
Neph, he is very...
He does the offensive stuff very often.
Like he'll jump frequently.
He's at the right time.
He's also super optimal in every situation.
Yeah, like right here.
Nice DP, get him off.
Woo, that's the toes.
Woo.
Nice block.
Oh, Superman punch.
That was sick.
I like that.
That's some jury only tech.
Yeah.
Blitz.
Oh.
He was mashing that shit down.
God damn.
Oh, what the fuck?
He almost had him.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't even know what that was.
Yes.
Oh, nice.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Eat it.
Oh, my God.
Big punish.
To the corner we go.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
It was on purpose.
American reset.
Oh, my God.
Oh, Superman punch.
Let's go, Bryan.
Oh, Superman.
Let's fucking go.
Dude, we're calling shit out today.
Let's go.
Woo.
One more, coach.
I wish this was Sunday.
Yeah, I wish this was the finals.
I'm done after this.
This feels like Sunday.
Sunday.
Blocks.
What the fuck?
So much defense here.
Yeah.
All right, all right.
Yeah, that's just Juri in a nutshell.
She just overwhelms you.
Yeah.
The zoning.
Oh, nice.
The defense is on point, though.
Holy shit.
It's just whoever messes up first.
Mm-hmm.
Which is scary.
Nice anti-air.
Nice.
Oh, nice carry.
Oh, that works.
Oh, my God.
Is that level one?
Level one, yeah.
Let's save, I think.
Oh, damn.
Back in the corner.
All right.
Here we go.
Good reactions.
Oh.
This is rough.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was close.
Yeah.
All right.
GG.
That was intense, though.
That was super intense.
Yeah.
That was close.
It was.
And you had him in that last move.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it does a ton of chip.
I didn't realize how much chip that did.
I think Lily's back for real.
Oh, flip.
Heads.
Every time heads, you're not...
I swear to God, if I get P2, I have heads.
You're an always rock player, aren't you?
All right.
Hold on.
Doki is the main event.
Yeah, true.
No.
You're the tiebreaker now, right?
Yeah, you are the tiebreaker, Doki.
No pressure.
No pressure, Doki, but you are the tiebreaker.
I reserved myself, all right.
Right.
We don't go to TwitchCon if you don't win this, remember?
Okay.
Yeah, remember that.
It's okay.
We don't need TwitchCon.
We have the power of friendship together.
Yeah, who needs TwitchCon?
We can watch party together.
I don't remember if Lily jumps this.
Oh, she does.
Okay.
Okay, sorry.
I'm out of my groove because of this.
Oh, she jumps a lot.
You know what to do.
Yeah.
Let's go.
All right.
She hits through that.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
I thought she was going to jump.
Yeah.
All right.
You got this, Doki.
Let's go.
Oh.
Nice.
She hits.
Damn.
Yep.
Let's conserve your meter.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot that.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, so close.
Do I hit this?
I do.
Okay.
Do I hit this?
Yes.
The classic.
Okay.
You're going to need one more hit.
Yeah.
One more.
He might super on wake up.
No, but he might super.
I mean, just the overhead will be nice.
Just block.
What?
That's so unfortunate.
I don't know what that move was.
Yeah, that's just hard.
Yeah.
Familiarity.
Smiley out of range.
But you had the right read.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
You got this.
That would have been sick.
Okay.
There you go.
There we go.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
Go ham.
Do your thing.
Okay.
She's burnt out.
Nice jump.
Oh.
You can do DI, yeah.
Okay.
I didn't remember that's a plus.
Is that what it's called?
You got it.
Is that what plus means?
Okay.
Yes.
That is a plus.
Now that I know what plus means.
Almighty.
Yeehaw.
Yeah.
But keep playing.
But yeah, just don't do too many drive rushes right now.
Get closer.
Okay.
So she has no stores.
Going.
Get closer to her.
So she's going to do that move randomly and fly at you.
Yeah.
Let's go, my loyal fans.
Well played.
My loyal fans.
I hate, I hate playing against Lily.
That's my bird.
It never changes.
It's so hard to predict.
It's like...
Nice.
Almighty.
Yeehaw.
Yeah.
Now she's...
Oh, she jumps now.
Yeah, but she's plus there.
So you want to jump.
Don't do triangle after that one.
That's when you got to get away from her.
So she has it.
Now she's going to do it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Take that.
Woo wee.
Go ham.
Okay, she's going to do it again.
Did I jump this?
You just keep moving towards her and blocking.
Okay, she has three of them.
So she's going to try to throw one at you randomly.
But you can try to jump at her with like X if you get a little closer.
But if she does the move, just block and jump.
Oh.
That's fine.
It's okay.
Composure.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, just block.
You can try like dry rush overhead.
But like a burst option.
But if she does that move, you know what to do.
Oh.
That shit was like American Ninja, dude.
That was so sick.
That's a neutral game.
That's the neutral Doki.
You get your side now.
Doki, you get your side.
Oh my god.
I'm on the side.
I'm not used to that.
No.
Alright.
Now we got excuses.
Cause she been playing.
Go in.
Okay.
I did not mean to do that, but okay.
Now you can go in.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
You can keep the pressure up.
Oh my god.
She's disgusting.
That's so funny.
That was...
I love this face of Doki.
You hated the shit out of her.
Okay.
That's fine.
You don't have to worry about it.
I don't know.
I think she died.
Oh my god.
She's so sick.
Here they go.
Doki, you are actually a menace, dude.
You are undefeated on this team.
Did you know that?
You won the tiebreaker for us.
You won the tiebreaker.
We're going to TwitchCon.
Ryan would not have had to play this.
No, Brian wouldn't have to play this.
All my faith in you guys.
Good job.
You are the only one on this team that's undefeated, Doki.
No, don't jinx me!
No pressure, though.
The jinx!
Did I lose?
No pressure.
Did you lose to the DJ?
No.
I think he lost to JP only.
No, I beat him.
Wait, where am I, dude?
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Wait a minute, do we have two people undefeated?
Hold on a minute, I'm lost.
I lost to Roy last time, not today.
Not yet.
Damn, alright!
No, no, no, that's the target.
That's crazy.
The only thing, BrawlPro, is that you're still doing a lot of nice SPDs.
That's the thing that got you killed against Roy.
Let's just minimize that.
I'll just chill on it.
I mean, who are you fighting against?
Diaphone's team, though?
It's Fi, and then also Roy is left.
Against PDX.
Who am I fighting?
Who's the next game?
Apparently, Shine, 5-0, Diaphone's team.
That's crazy, holy shit.
That's actually really good.
That's not good for us.
I'm really hoping that the next team just destroys them.
Is it updating?
Yeah, it is.
It's automatic now, the scores.
Yeah, it's on round day 2 results.
Um...
I don't know.
Our points aren't updating.
Nah, not yet.
I think we gotta wait till the end.
And then we can audit again, you know?
Oh no, there is an update.
They played more games than us, though.
If we look at it right now, it's not over.
We have the most points by 50.
We have 50, the next one has 30.
So that's...
Well, we're ahead.
My chat's saying we're like two wins behind Nephew's team.
Damn, that'd be sick.
Well, is that overall?
I guess.
To be fair, though, Sunday is where this shit matters for real.
But we get a buy, though.
If we get the buy, we're automatically...
I need to get top of the leaderboard, you don't understand.
Do we automatically go to TwitchCon?
No, that's not true.
No, we have to win only one if we get a buy.
Okay.
We have to go to TwitchCon.
If we get a buy.
If we don't get a buy, we have to win two.
That's a lot.
Two is more than one.
So on Sunday, what are they gonna do?
Only, like, we'll only have to play one time?
Because they want to do the top four at TwitchCon?
Yeah.
Because only four teams make it in.
Wait, that's gonna be a really fast finals.
Yeah.
Maybe Seijin has some other stuff planned.
Maybe there'll be show matches.
Possibly.
Maybe.
Okay, they should put us up against JB's team.
For the first game.
Yeah, can we do that?
I love those guys, I think.
But, I don't know.
What do we have here?
We'll have to run to the bathroom though.
I'll be right back.
Oh, I don't have the...
No, it should be Trinity.
But it's from Slamman.
I only have Slamman and Claire.
That's it.
Yeah, Slamman is Trinity.
Trinity's in the lobby.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, Trinity is in the lobby.
Trinity said the CFN we're looking for is Trinity 5.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I don't have...
You're saying they're in the Slamman lobby?
Yeah, they're in the Slamman lobby.
I'm literally with the Trinity 5 people.
Well, why is JB in here?
Yeah, I was like, why is he in here?
Oh, okay.
So we're not the crazy ones.
Okay, cool.
I was like, what are you talking about?
He's right here.
Okay.
Cool.
Alright.
I don't know if I played enough against...
I heard that Sykkuno practiced hard against...
This is Sykkuno?
I heard he practiced really hard against Gif, so I'm like a little nervous.
My only note for you against Sykkuno...
was LOL.
Yeah, I saw that!
I was like, oh no, he could've learned new moves!
I wrote like a page and a half for you.
Or two pages total, but Sykkuno's one line.
Yeah.
I think it was too quick!
No, it's cause like, literally before the tournament started, I got him in rank and it tilted him.
But I didn't play rank today, so I don't know...
I didn't play rank today.
So I don't know if it tilted him or not.
If he's gonna be tilted or not.
Yeah, I didn't realize until after.
It's like, oh, he went four and one only losing to you.
I heard the strat is he does jab, jab, jab and if it hits, he goes to spiral arrow.
Yeah, he spams jab a lot.
That's what I noticed.
So if you block that, then it's over and he'll just cancel the DI and you can counter DI.
So blocking when he knocks you down might be good.
But everything else you're doing when you're attacking is just keep doing it.
He already lost the match, just to let you know.
Okay, nice.
So his confidence has been shooketh.
Shooketh.
He's got a crown.
He's gonna crumble this side of Doki.
I cannot get over this frame one P one side strat that she's got going.
Everyone's got She's got everyone playing heads or tails.
The influence right now.
Oh my gosh.
The influence that this bird has.
Why is it, dude?
This is rigged.
It's good.
It's like Uno chose heads.
Oh, Diddy.
Oh, my bad.
You know what side.
That's funny.
Leave the queue.
Here comes a new challenger.
All right.
I don't remember how he plays though.
I didn't bump into him in rank.
That's the only reason I remember how he plays.
The only thing is if he knocks you down, just try to block for a little while and then he'll do DI.
But everything else, just keep doing what you're doing.
Is this Slamman or Last Clair?
Slamman.
Okay.
Yeah, so he does DI like that.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, he started grabbing now.
That's good for him.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I wanted to grab him first, but he got me.
Yeah, he's jumping and throwing.
So he's throwing over and over.
Yeah.
Okay, that's his strat now.
He's just going to try to throw you over and over.
Yeah, he's trying to throw you at me.
This is quite a match.
Yeah, that's nice.
If he jumps and throws, you can just punish him on the ground.
Oh, okay.
When he's jumping in the air like that and whiffing a throw, just throw him when he lands.
Okay.
That's very not real.
Nice!
Nice.
Okay.
That's okay.
There's a tickle.
Oh, he's on classic?
Yeah, he is.
Oh my god, did y'all see that?
The combo?
Nice punish.
Oh, the booty.
We got a focus squad.
It's hard!
Yeah!
Nice one, Doki!
Nice!
Do that again.
About to start breaking out the dollar bills real soon here.
And you remember, he's looking to throw now.
Nice try.
Block that move.
Thank you, Doki.
Nice, good patience.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
That was so sick.
That was actually so good.
Doki's actually tanked.
Oh my goodness!
She's cracked!
That was okay.
Alright, that's good.
Well played, well played.
I legit think she's the best player.
I don't know what I'm doing!
What the hell?
I'm not strategizing, I'm just playing.
Listen, you can sandbag for your opponents, but you can come clean to us.
I'm literally just...
My head is just like...
I do... okay, I do this now.
Like...
Yeah, and it worked!
Nah, dude.
Let's do it, dude.
I'm about to jump out the window.
I can't, dude.
Okay.
Dude, you're giving him emotional damage.
He's not gonna be the same person after this.
Oh.
He throws me first, cause I...
Okay.
He gets your look back!
Let's go.
He's blind!
Toki, he's blind!
I don't know if he jumps.
Does he jump?
No, he doesn't.
Okay.
Oh god!
One more.
He's gonna be broken after this.
He doesn't know what's going on.
No!
Let's go, Toki.
Okay.
It's over.
Let's go, Toki.
It's crazy.
5-0, Sykuna.
5-0.
This is crazy.
Nah, this is insane.
I'm losing my mind here.
So who are you fighting?
I can't believe that Toki has footsies.
So, Eske, the only thing about Amore is...
He DI'd so much.
He DI'd a bunch, and also...
He jumps back a lot, too.
The medium punch, heavy punch target combo?
Yeah.
They always do medium punch, heavy punch.
And that's just unsafe on block.
And if they cancel to DI, you DI back.
So it's that one, two punch.
Always spams that.
And you can just press medium punch after.
And if they DI cancel it, you cancel your medium to DI.
Other than that, player game.
I still don't know what I'm doing.
Toki, I never want you to know what neutral is.
We need to keep you as pure as possible.
I believe in you, Eske.
Thank you.
Eske, you got this, Chica.
It's a battle of the... I think we're both one and something.
Or like two and six.
This is about to be your second dub.
I think you both went one and four the first day, I think.
Yup, yup.
Now she's gonna be one and four.
Believe in you.
It didn't start, did it?
No, we're waiting.
We need to wait a second.
Okay, okay, I got it.
I'm going now.
They gotta give Sykkuno some therapy real quick.
I can't believe we're making the Triforce of birds, dude.
We got Angry Bird, Big Bird, and now Doki Bird.
Triforce of birds, dude.
I got the bird in me.
I got that bird in me.
With the power of the birds.
I think you sent Sykkuno to therapy.
I'm getting that.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's new.
Nice.
Oh.
No worries, no worries.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Ouch.
Yeah, they're gonna spam that and then throw you after.
Okay.
Dragon Lash.
It's plus?
You can DP it.
Oh, I can DI it?
Oh, DP it.
You can DI it or DP it, but it's just hard to react to, but if you block, she's plus.
That's all.
Ha!
Oh, bro, you left.
Yeah, it kicked me out.
That's toxic.
Oh, it kicked me out.
I'm toxic.
Talking that shit.
That's what you get.
Nice.
Nice grab.
Good try.
Let's wait a second here.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, they're really good at countering DI, but they will also throw a random DI.
I'm not gonna press it anymore.
Yeah, it's just...
That's about it.
Do I just need to hold block more?
You're mashing sweep, crouching heavy kick.
I want you to not use that move.
That's a new habit I think you got since I last saw you.
Don't use that.
Okay.
It's getting you killed in all these matches I've noticed.
So if you can just, in those moments, just block a little bit more.
And then you're good.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, Sycuna reported me.
You're jumping over all of my...
Fireballs.
All of... yeah.
Yeah.
You gotta back up and let them jump.
Okay.
This is the type of player where you kinda let them come to you.
And if you get the DP knockdown, then you can dry rush in medium, and then if they block that, go for a throw or something.
But they're gonna always jump forward, or they're gonna always do dragon lash.
And both those options could be interrupted by DP, or, you know, dragon lash with DI.
But they're...
If you get too close to them, they're gonna try to jump over you, and that's gonna be really awkward to anti-air.
So if you keep distance and then get knockdown, then dry rush when you get a clean knockdown, you can pressure.
If your pressure ends, don't mash sweep.
That's not a good habit to have.
So just block it out.
Okay.
And then maybe backdash once you block a few moves and try again.
Okay, got it.
Let's go.
Let's go, SK!
Let's go!
I'm rooting.
You gave her that hesitation.
Iced her out.
I wanna make the pouty face.
Yeah, get those mind games in the pre-lobby.
Yeah.
Gotta do this.
Come on.
Oops.
Hadouken!
Dragon buzzy, actually.
Yeah, there you go.
Nice.
Yeah, they messed up.
Yeah.
How can I watch?
How's this?
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Oh, nice.
Nice tech.
Ooh.
There we go.
Oh, yeah!
Cool.
I pressed sweep.
Not bad.
That's fine.
No, that was a punish.
Sweeps with sweeps.
That's great.
Okay, okay.
But otherwise, this is chill.
But you're doing great.
Ow.
Just the idea to block.
And now it's time to DI.
Yes!
So good, actually.
Oh, I'm old.
No, it's okay.
You couldn't DI cancel that.
Yeah, you did a cancelable move.
So you can't DI there.
Still DI when her back is against the wall, low on HP.
It's like a trump card.
Yeah.
Okay.
She said, oh, I'm old.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
That's a sick jump.
What?
What did I just saw?
Nice grab.
She's gonna mash something.
Let's go.
Oh, nice.
Nice!
Get her!
What a jump!
Holy shit!
Great.
That jump was insane.
Jumpy.
I'm going in.
Oh, I like that.
Block.
Oh, block.
Nice.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Get her!
Oh my god!
She jumped!
You caught her!
You caught her jump!
It wasn't a combo, but we take those.
It was a read.
She knew the jump was coming.
Okay, yeah.
No more.
They will try to DI you, and you will stop it.
Oh, okay.
That was great.
That was an awesome time to dry rush in also.
Let's go!
EMSK, let's go!
Okay.
Good interrupt.
Oops.
That's fine.
Just block, yeah.
Oh, I pressed just...
See?
You gotta press medium into DI there, yeah.
You're so bad.
That's cool.
Just block it out.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
You see the game plan.
Yep.
My DI reactions are broken today.
It's okay.
Finals is what matters.
Yep.
Yeah.
This is...
It's like practice run number two.
Good parries.
Oh.
Time to DP out.
Amore.
Oh my god, Amore.
Oh, nice.
She pressed that.
That was not a reaction.
Yeah, she's just doing DI.
You got this.
And now she's out of meter.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Time to go in.
Only gotta worry about her super.
That's it.
That's good.
Just block.
Nice.
Good defense.
Nice try.
Good try.
Oh, man.
Amore is a DI monster.
I know, right?
What the heck is that?
That's crazy.
It's okay.
More training.
More training for Sunday.
Yeah.
Yeah, once you recognize that they're literally just always gonna do DI, it'll click.
When I play ranked, I react like 90% of the time.
I think it's just like tournament issues.
Tournament is a different piece.
Yeah.
Yes.
And they did do it slightly like different timing, but yeah.
I feel ya.
It happens.
Good try.
Right.
I hate Cammy.
It's cool.
It's okay.
They hate Zangief.
Okay.
Oh, I tried to SPD.
Didn't work.
Nice.
There you go.
That's a good button for this match.
Oops.
Oh, it's all right.
You grappled him.
It's all right.
She's burned out.
No worries.
Oh, no.
You're burned out.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
Wrong one.
Never mind.
One guy is a buffy wrestler.
That was good for him.
Yeah.
Just don't...
Be more reserved with your drive meter.
Do like drive rush after SPD to crash medium kick.
He's jumping a lot.
He's holding up back.
Just do the light stuff to keep him pinned down a little bit.
And then do jump MK.
Keep empty jumping.
He's not gonna DP or jump MK.
And if he does, good shit.
Fuck it.
Yeah, that's good.
Look at his drive meter.
Threaten something.
Oh!
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, conserve your drive meter for a little while.
Okay.
Oh, man.
If you knew that...
If you knew the air grab, I've been sick.
It's not the same as pressing triangle.
If only he had a single button.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
There we go.
All right.
Strike.
Come on, strike!
Remember, Larry beats all the shenanigans.
Nice.
Nice block.
Nice grab!
That was a big grab, too.
Let's go.
Oh!
He's mashing.
Okay, let's not do that.
That's too much.
Yeah.
Level 3.
Okay.
He's still alive.
Is that kill?
You're still alive.
No, no.
He's still alive.
And he's burned out, so...
And he has level 3.
Nice check.
Oh, that hesitation there.
Yeah.
Oh!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
Can you try jump MK a little more?
That's the only thing, man.
Yeah.
There you go.
Perfect.
You're cooking.
I tried a reversal, but he whiffed.
Yeah.
I feel you.
That's annoying.
Nice.
Nice chop.
He's out nuching now.
That's fine.
Expensive for him.
Yeah.
Look how little damage he did there.
Mm!
The first chop!
Oh, slap him!
You're out nuching now.
Yep.
You're playing better.
Get him!
Yeah!
Oh yeah, baby!
He's mashing!
Fuck yeah!
Of course!
Oh yeah.
Get that combo.
That's all good.
Yeah.
Drop the punish.
Okay.
Oh, I tried to lower again.
Oh yeah.
He be mashing for sure.
That's so fine.
Oh!
After that spinny kick, she's negative four, so you can jab or medium.
Mm-hmm.
There you go.
Are you winning?
I can't tell.
I got kicked out.
Oh yeah, baby!
Oh, you got him on the ropes.
Oh no!
I failed to log in.
I can share screen for you.
Wait.
I haven't even logged in.
I'm restarting my game.
All right.
Oh, nice anti earlier.
Oh no!
The QSK.
All right, guys.
Give me a sec.
There's an update?
Oh, you're alive.
You're alive.
Oh, you got this.
Nice!
Oh!
So close!
You're playing good.
You got this.
Just...
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
What the fuck did he just do?
Oh, this is dry rush.
Cancel.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
That was...
Yeah.
That one on the head?
That's a free drip jab.
Mm-hmm.
Nice!
Oh, nice!
Headbutt, man.
That's fine.
All right.
I'm back in.
Thank you for letting me swatch.
Nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice reversal.
You got plenty of health.
It's like cool.
Oh, my God.
Oh, what's going on?
Okay.
Just get that last poke.
That's fine.
Composure.
You can't kill.
Nice.
Nice defense.
Oh, no.
Okay.
It's fine.
You're alive.
You're good.
Oh, God.
Damn it.
Oh, no.
That was close.
And these stare downs.
Remember, you got your stand MK.
You got your pokes.
He's lulling you into that game.
You can use them occasionally.
Okay.
Not always, but just use them occasionally.
Especially when you got to tap it in.
You got this, brother.
Leave for all pro.
You got this.
Yeah, slap her.
She deserves it.
Oh, the people's chop.
Oh.
Yeah.
She a ho.
Slap her.
Oh, I didn't say that.
Okay.
She's just a bad person.
Yeah.
She's a terrible person.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's okay.
Nice.
Nice army.
Best friend.
The corner.
Nice predict.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, they're freaking out.
Oh, no.
Now you're in the corner.
Damn it.
Oh.
That's fine.
He's in the corner.
He's going to try to jump out or something.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Nice attack.
Nice.
You have to drive rush knee or get in there.
You have ways to get in if she's doing too much from way far away.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
That's a good combo.
I used the drive meter for a little bit.
But you can walk up.
Yeah.
You can still walk at them.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Nice bait.
Oh, I see.
I see you.
You're good.
Nice.
I love your fans.
Yes.
One more.
Tap it in.
Yes.
Let's go.
Yes, sir.
The Geef players are undefeated.
This is...
There's something wrong here.
Let's go.
Oh, man.
Maybe we should have all just been Geef guys.
Maybe...
You're right.
I'm starting to think I should have been Geef.
Yeah.
That happens in the future brawl.
Like...
Yeah.
When you guys are staring at each other from full screen, Geef just has drive rush knee.
Like, that's your, like, fuck it.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's the only, like, ham move you're not using when you can.
Got it.
Like, you're doing a shit ton of drive rush cancels, though, so you're burning yourself out super early.
Okay.
So, if you minimize using those and just...
If you're...
If he's walking back and forth trying to play proper neutral, just say, fuck it, you're going to check my drive rush knee?
Probably not.
And if that gets in, you're plussed instantly in their face.
Okay.
Got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I will use that more.
Yeah.
It could have been easier, I feel like.
But you...
Yeah.
You read him really well.
That was really difficult.
Yes.
Yeah.
It really was.
And I actually thought about waking up level three-ing when I died the round before, but I didn't think about it in time.
It would have worked, too, but yeah.
Eh.
That's all guessing, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's grab.
Yes, sir.
Oh.
Nice.
Nice jump out.
There you go.
Exactly.
Nice.
There you go.
What the fuck?
Just nuttiness.
I don't even know why.
What the fuck was that?
I didn't...
There you go.
It was empty.
So just remember, he can modern level one your DI, so you can rush him down normal.
Yeah.
Nice throw.
Nice.
Oh.
No.
Not against modern, yeah.
Yeah.
Modern will just pop that uppercut.
Just throw him over and over.
There we go.
Nice.
Nice combo.
Yeah.
That was a good whiff punish by him.
Nice.
Yeah.
Pick up.
Nice grab.
Oh my gosh.
What a fucking grab.
Just think this is Rink.
That is so...
Nice drink.
So he's waiting to...
Yeah.
He's waiting to react.
Nice.
Be careful.
Oh.
Fuck me, man.
That's so close.
Yeah.
Wait a moment.
Do you ever parry the fireballs?
You can parry all these fireballs.
Yeah.
I should be.
You should be thinking every time you see that, try to parry it.
And then you can try to drive rush potentially after the fireball.
And that's your gap.
Otherwise, you're doing good.
You know, you can try to jump out of the corner like you're doing.
But when you're doing offense on him, just keep it super simple.
Don't ever do the jump throw bait, whatever.
Just throw him or do like drive rush medium or drive rush towards heavy kick.
Just keep it strike throw because anything with a reaction test, he's going to pass.
Okay.
So that's about it.
Like if he's in that zone fireballing you, just try to parry them.
And then, yeah, remember to jump out of the corner because you can eat an uppercut when you have enough life and go back to mid-screen.
He'll drive rush at you after you uppercut him.
And then he'll try to neutral jump in your face to throw bait you.
If he throws you mid-screen, let it happen.
Eat a DP and a throw.
At that point, you're back to mid-screen.
Just neutral.
Just quick rise and you're good.
It's a nice combo.
Oh my god.
Nice combo.
Meaty.
Oh, is he dead?
He's fucking dead.
Oh my god.
The adaptation!
Nice.
Oh.
Nice defense, Ko.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Nice.
Nice defense, Ko.
Yeah.
Let the drive rush ride.
Oh!
What is he even saying?
Head blast?
Uh, what is...
I don't know.
Sand blast.
What in the fuck is that even?
Don't worry about it.
Let's go, Ko.
Don't worry about it, Doki.
Sorry.
We did it!
Oh!
And now he's burned.
Nice!
Now he's gonna look for level one, but you're good.
What?
Block?
Not...
Nice!
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go!
That was sick.
Oh, he has like pocket sand.
That's my last blue player right there.
He's showing his pocket sand at you.
Nice blocks.
Oh, nice grab!
All right.
Nice grab.
Just watch your drive meter and you should be okay.
Nice!
Excellent jump.
Nice.
Push.
Oh, he doesn't know what to do!
Oh.
Sequence.
Oh!
Yes, sir.
Oh my god.
Holy shit!
What the fuck am I watching?
That's fine.
Good defense.
Yes!
Drive rush meter!
Yes, sir!
That's what I'm talking about.
Let's go, Ko.
Is my poison kicking in?
Damn.
One, two, three!
Jeez.
What the fuck?
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Boxbox plays like a gorilla, man.
Thank god he's on modern.
That did barely anything.
Yeah.
Last season, that would have done so much more, too.
Nice punish!
Nice.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god!
The first level three!
What the dang!
I love this character.
Let's go!
I love this character, man.
Because of this.
Oh!
Just blocked?
Nice!
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
Nice and easy.
Patience.
Let's go, man.
Oh, technically, you won the set.
We did it!
And, coach, you wouldn't have had to play, either.
Yeah, you won the play!
Thank you.
Oh, really?
If this was Sunday, we wouldn't have to play.
Hell yeah!
Yeah, it was the 3-0.
Yeah, 3-1.
Thank you, guys.
But we do need him to play for the points, though.
That's all right.
Yeah.
We need you to play.
I guess I'll try.
I guess.
I like how Kolo always forgets to leave the thing.
He forgets to leave the lobby every time.
He's still forgetting.
Oh!
I definitely got lucky with those, like, jump-ins.
Oh, he still doesn't realize.
Oh!
Fuck me!
Sorry!
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Now we can revel in the victory.
Now you can start talking about it.
Yeah.
Woo!
I've been chugging water to fight the nerves.
What the hell?
Hold on a minute.
I gotta...
Did he pick the wrong character?
Wait.
He's...
Okay.
There we go.
Oh.
Sorry.
There we go.
What?
Oh, yeah.
I was gonna be like, what?
Did we pick the wrong coach, though?
I was like, oh, shit.
All right.
I'm stalling a little bit.
I'm gonna get some water while I'm...
I gotta pee, bro.
But I gotta watch this, too, though.
I'm telling you, bro.
Bro.
I'm gonna pee.
Don't for Roy.
Save the piss puff for Roy.
Dude, that doesn't work.
It works.
I promise.
Yippee!
Nice.
Stand still.
Oh my.
Nice block.
The flush.
Oh my.
Nice one in.
Oookay.
Oh my.
Oh!
The counter grab.
Holy cuck.
Oh, she doesn't need the meter!
Oh, send that back.
That's really Dragon Ball Z.
Yeah, it is!
Yeah, stand the fuck still.
Oh, nice!
Oh my gosh.
Nice, Perfect Parry!
Ball time!
That combo is so sick.
It looks so cool.
That's like the sickest combo in the game.
I wish it does more damage.
Oh my god, Brian!
Let's go, Brian!
The coach is locked in.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh my lord.
Holy shit.
He is hella locked in because he knows it's fine.
He has a variety.
He has a weekend ahead of him.
He doesn't have to worry about work tomorrow.
He doesn't have to worry about the 9-5.
Yeah.
Another Perfect Parry?!
He doesn't have meter though.
Where are we at, team?
Brian's cooking.
Brian's gonna set.
That's one more round.
Brian's cooking.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, let's go.
That's fucking awesome.
Oh, that's free.
Yeah, yeah.
That's the only thing he could do.
It's level 1, right?
Yeah, it's level 1.
Okay, so...
Oh yeah, he just barely got it back.
Yeah.
That was a good timing.
Just barely.
The frame, it came back.
Yeah.
This guy's been watching coefficient.
The coach is watching coefficient.
He's been taking notes.
Well, that was good.
That was, yeah.
Oh, he met... Oh, I know.
He did a frame kill.
Oh, nice jump.
Nice jump.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, ball time!
I love that move.
Here we go.
Time for ball.
Oh, the desync.
Here we go.
On both sides.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, that was... Yeah, he messed up a little bit, but it's okay.
Yeah, but he got confused.
Oh, nice jab.
Oh my gosh.
Not gonna kill.
We're gonna keep going.
Oh.
Nice jump out, though.
Yeah.
Oh, they're burnt out.
Gotta be careful here.
Oh, nice flicker.
Oh, ball time.
Oh, you have to deal with it.
You have to deal with it now.
Yeah.
No, that ball when you're burnt out.
Nah, dude.
Yeah, it's just impossible.
Impossible for him.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that was tricky.
Yeah, no, she's a little freaky.
Okay.
Nice jump out.
Nice.
Let's go.
Taking his own advice.
Oh, yeah.
Aki has that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Safe jumps.
Good.
That was good.
Come here.
Get over here.
Oh, it's the blitz.
You get a combo off of that.
Oh, nice jump.
Oh, my God.
He's desperate.
It's okay.
Composure.
Nice tech.
Oh, she doesn't have it.
Oh, they're burnt out.
Let's go.
Yeah, good reactions.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
No, Diafone's reactions are insane.
All right.
Composure.
No worries.
They'll burnt out.
Oh, time to throw this out.
We're seeing it again.
Time to throw.
You got to deal with this ball now.
Yup.
Oh, yeah.
That was crazy.
That guy is crazy.
Let's go, dude.
How did you know?
That was so good.
That was sick.
Nah, dude.
You got to tell me.
How did you know?
Did you know he was going to do that?
That was insane.
Nah, I didn't.
I just knew he was in a bad spot.
Oh, cool.
Hey, all right.
Good job.
That was crazy.
He does that.
He gets fucked.
He doesn't block low.
It's a high-low mix and beats drive reversal.
That was insane.
Dude, the checkmate was awesome.
Yeah.
Good stuff.
That was incredible, bro.
I love watching all your sets so far, dude.
They're so good, dude.
Yeah, they're all intense as hell.
This might as well be Sunday.
Oh, come on.
I wish it was, dude.
Mr. Jam Man.
Please.
Just let this be Sunday.
Yeah, let's just...
Let's just let this be Sunday.
The teams with the most points go to the finals.
Go to the TwitchCon.
They just win.
The team with the most...
The team with the most points.
Yeah, but that'd be Nephew.
What do you mean?
Oh, damn.
Coach, you just gave my chat a huge payout, apparently.
Yeah, fuck you guys, chat.
How do you not believe in my coach, huh?
How could they?
How could they do that?
I know, right?
I beat Dynaphone last time, too.
Yeah, exactly.
They're just hating, man.
No, dude.
Don't worry.
I'm going to give them a nice scolding.
They're haters.
Chat, you and I are going to have a talk after this, all right?
All right.
Bathroom break again.
Bathroom break.
Oh, I need hot water.
Break time.
To the last match here.
Yeah.
So, we played the same team last year.
Automatic.
Okay, cool.
Last year.
Do you guys don't remember?
See, this is what I mean.
I can't speak when playing.
Last year.
I start losing motor function.
Yeah.
The games are still going on for other people.
ShinySea might have another 5-0.
They currently have 1-5-0 right now.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
And their other matchup is 4-0 at the moment.
Man.
Oh, man.
So, they're...
It's a coach's match.
All right.
What is Shine's...
We almost did a 5-0.
Almost.
It is close.
Yeah.
We haven't lost a single leg set, technically.
I think we're the best performing team today.
I agree.
100%.
So, we're in the leading points overall right now.
Best performing?
I don't know.
Because Shine is on, like, a crazy streak.
Yeah.
Shine is on, like...
Like a 9-0.
9-0 streak right now.
Team Shine.
They have a 5-0.
Wait.
I think they...
I think they had another 5-0.
So, they're about to do a 5-0.
No.
They just got the 5-B.
Oh.
They did.
They just got...
They got two 5-0s.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Us and Shine's team are doing the best today.
But we beat them overall.
Right?
So, that's good for us.
Yeah.
We did beat them overall.
We gate-hipped them from some points.
Let's go!
All that matters.
I think we...
There's a potential...
Yeah.
Shine is doing a lot.
We could get second if we do well in the next set because Nepia's team isn't doing so hot this round...
This...
Today.
Right now, we're in the lead in points overall.
As of right now in the score sheet, for day one and two, we are in first place right now.
Oh, nice!
Hell yeah, dude.
I don't know if it has to update a bunch.
It's kind of hard to read.
I think Shine and JB's team hasn't updated yet.
Yeah.
So, it's going to be like a race between us, Shine's team, and Nepia's team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a clear division right now.
We're pulling ahead.
Like, us three.
So, I think we're...
That'd be sick.
Like, let's clean it up, but we're looking really good for winners.
Oh, it just updated it.
Did it just update?
Who's Automatic?
That's right.
Who's Team Automatic?
Oh, the DJ.
ASNW.
Okay.
Oh, we're tied at 109 with Shine.
Yeah.
So, Automatic is...
Yeah, but overall...
I feel like there's a clear divide, like us, Shine, and Nephew.
So...
Okay.
Cool.
Let's just close out strong.
Whee!
Oh,
SK.
So, you're Ken.
Yeah.
I think you fight another Ken now.
And the thing is, they do a lot of the same thing.
Okay.
Minus the Dragon Lash.
Oh, I'm sorry.
They do the same idea of like the medium punch, heavy punch, and DI.
Oh, Shine and Nephew face each other last.
So, if Nephew loses against Shine, then we do really well in our matches.
We can get second or first.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, we're good for winners is what I think.
Right?
I think we're just...
It's only bottom two go to losers.
Right?
We just want to be top four.
Yeah.
So, let's just close out strong.
And we should be set.
Yeah.
Should be good.
SK, the same idea with...
I think they're going to be weaker.
They're not going to be as good at doing DP and Dragon Lash, but they're going to do medium punch, heavy punch, and then they're going to do DI.
So, if you can press medium punch there in return and DI back in the rest of your regular game plan, it should be fine.
But they also do...
Does Seratina jump?
Seratina?
That's your question?
The Eki.
Yeah, yeah.
Does she jump?
I don't remember.
They do...
She waits for your DI in the corner.
That's what I...
Oh, yeah.
She does the counter DI.
Okay.
So, as long as I don't DI.
Yeah.
So, just don't use DI against her.
Just walk up to her and press triangle or do like jump X and get in.
You know, she's waiting for you to DI, so that lets you do your other moves like your jumps.
Okay.
So, we're currently tied with Shyvana now.
Yeah, yeah.
But they're facing Nephew, so like no matter what, like Nephew's going to...
Oh, okay.
So, they have a tough one.
One of them are going to drop points.
Either of them.
Yeah, yeah.
Which is...
Oh, that's...
Oh, man.
Oh, boy.
So, we just have to do well on this set and we're guaranteed second or first.
No guarantees, but we're going to kill this.
Let's do this.
Yippee.
Let's go.
Actually, what's their challenge?
I love that our training is showing results.
Yeah.
You guys put in work.
It really has.
I beat those.
I beat those two that beat me.
I think fighting viewers was more productive than doing rank, what I've learned.
Because then I can like figure out the matchups much easier because I kick anybody else...
I kick anybody that's not playing the character.
I'm playing against.
And you also play more than one game.
Yeah.
See.
Because I'm not losing either.
There's something to it.
And I don't care.
Damn.
There's something to it, right?
Exposed.
There's something to it, yeah.
Oh, thanks, Justin.
Thanks, Justin.
For what?
Oh, Justin just came in.
He's like, I'm doing good.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like Brian gives a...
That's how I'm feeling right now.
Remember who made you that video you didn't want.
That's how I'm feeling.
I watched the video after this.
But you know what's crazy?
Justin is my coach.
Oh, shit.
I did...
They have a semi-pro thing for Street Fighter called Street Fighter League.
And I was in season one.
And he was my captain.
Oh, yay.
Yeah.
And he was a godlike captain and coach.
Like, he gives you such good advice.
Like, yeah.
So shout out to him.
Shout out to Justin.
Oh, my god.
Let's go, Justin.
He's like grandpa coach over there.
Dude, I'm so tempted to do the knock-knock feature on Sajam.
I want to collaborate with him.
You heard the reason why this feature is going to get taken down.
Sajam.
Twitch, this guy, coefficient, keeps knocking on my stream.
I want to knock.
I want to collaborate, Sajam.
Come on.
What a strange feature, dude.
I'm going to be knocking on your door real soon, coach.
Does anybody actually use that feature?
Like...
I don't know.
No.
Like when...
Twitch just focuses on the wrong things.
It's very strange.
Damn.
Okay, so we're going to be on stage two.
We haven't sent invites yet, so we're just chilling.
Yeah, I'm not waiting.
Nah, I'm chilling.
Yeah.
I'm just watching the stream right now.
Oh, it's Kana and Lily right now.
Oh, yeah.
It's Shine.
We beat both these teams.
Oh, hell yeah.
All right.
We're freaking sick.
Welcome back.
Thanks.
We're just waiting for our lobby.
Do you feel less powerful now?
No.
I feel better.
I feel like a better human.
Co-efficient?
You got this all backwards, man.
Dude, I think your body's telling you the wrong information.
Yo, before a tournament, when you're pulled 15, 10 minutes out, you check in, you tell the bracket runner, be right back, and you go to the bathroom.
It's just what you do.
That's what I do.
Yeah.
I don't do that.
See, I think about the TO bracket runners, you know?
I was like, no, bro.
I took it.
We checked in.
We told them, and we'll be right back before the time is called.
I even asked them.
I was like, hey, I got enough time.
They're like, yeah, yeah, you're good.
Exactly.
That's the flow chart.
Not this psycho over here trying to hold it in the whole time.
I'm just, I'm telling you guys, the piss buff is real.
The thing is, like, the nerves make me thirsty, and then I've chugged so much water, and then I have to keep using the bathroom.
It sucks.
Oh, no.
These pretzels are making me thirsty.
Yo, I feel the same way, dude.
Yeah.
Oh, we got the code.
Oh, we got it?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You mean the invite?
Yeah, the invite.
Who's it gonna be from?
Stage one.
Is it The Bones?
I'll check.
Stage one.
Yeah, Bones.
It's The Bones.
Oh, Da Bones.
All right.
Let's finish this off.
Oh, I haven't even received mine.
Damn.
Oh, sorry, bro.
The piss keeps me sharp.
Exactly.
You're so mean.
It keeps me on edge.
We'll see how sharp you are after your match ends.
I'm telling you, bro.
Yeah.
You're sharp if you remember to leave the lobby after your match ends.
That's when we'll know.
You're locked in.
That's my only weakness right now.
I'll do it.
This time, I'm gonna remember to get out immediately.
Listen, if it lets you win, do whatever you gotta do.
Stay there.
Dance on their grave.
Okay.
What else does Seratina do?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
So, the only other thing she does is she likes to do the full-screen flying punch.
Oh, okay.
So, I just block that.
Yeah.
Just the one where she lays down and then goes, wah, and like dives at you.
If you block it, just press triangle or level three.
Okay.
Other than that, she's waiting for you to DI, so just don't use DI randomly like that.
Yeah.
I'll just grab more than...
Or jump.
Which is worse.
Which is worse for her.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
No!
She chose heads!
Don't worry.
Wait, hold on.
Come on.
No!
Well, damn, dude.
The one time, bro.
The one time I failed the coin flip.
God damn it.
Can I have P1?
Damn, bro.
What is this, dude?
Is everyone the older sibling?
Why doesn't anyone like player two, dude?
It's not.
It's because I'm left-brained.
I'm left-brained.
I'm left, right?
I can only process the left.
Wait, I don't remember...
Does she... I'm knowledge check.
I don't remember if she has the knowledge.
Does she have the knowledge?
If you know what that means, do it.
I don't know.
You're getting so solid, Doki.
One day, you don't have to do the knowledge check.
I mean, that says something about the coach.
Just letting you know.
Okay, she knows it.
She knows it.
It don't even matter.
We're good.
I'll just...
Walk her down.
Just walk her down.
Oh my god!
Exactly.
She doesn't drive, so I'll just walk up and grab.
She's trying to counter DI me, so I'll walk up.
They're gonna make you fight SK.
They're gonna make you fight SK's people, man.
I'm bad.
I swear.
I swear the guy.
Oh my lord.
I don't know.
I'm P1!
Let's go!
That's not right!
The real dub of the day.
Okay, I need to focus.
Oh my god.
She's got real combos.
That's not fair.
Well, you got real combos too.
Do I?
Yeah, do your real combos.
Oh no.
But she improved a lot.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Can we get a hand can?
Is this her playing?
Damn.
Proof?
Question mark?
That's fucking toxic.
Oh no.
I don't think you should be talking.
I don't think you should be talking right now.
Let's go.
I don't think you should be talking.
Modern has to be inhumane.
How can you just do that?
This makes me so mad because this is like a classic versus modern.
She's just having the time of her life.
And she's struggling over there.
Oh no, the DI.
She's really good at DI counting.
Yeah, she's not bad.
Nice.
She waits for that, so that's why triangle and everything else works.
Hey, go.
Good job.
Oh no.
Oh, the spacing.
That was a good idea, that was a good idea.
Yeah.
Oh, unlucky.
Yeah, that's fine.
The jump-ins are still a good idea.
Oh, she's gonna throw loop you.
Okay.
Can you focus?
Good parry.
Oh, that's the move.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck, goodbye.
That's alright.
You can find a jump.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
You're selling this.
Never say never.
Okay, it's okay, block it.
And walk up.
No!
Focus, I guess.
That's fine, you made her waste the meter.
I guess, I guess.
No worries.
Oh shit.
You're just like me for real.
What the hell.
Alright.
Oh, what?
That block stat?
Oh, she's...
Nice, keep her there.
Nice.
She improved a lot.
Yeah.
You did too, you did too.
You got this.
Oh no.
It's alright, it's alright.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Time to sit up, lock in Doki.
DI off the table against her, right?
DI off?
No, it's off the table.
Okay, no more DI's, okay.
Yeah, she's too good at counter DI.
Okay.
Jump X is still good, if you're close to her.
The squares are also your friend.
But beyond that, playing good.
Okay.
Yeah.
She's like waiting for me.
Yep.
Oh, I need to not do that.
Yeah, yeah.
She's throwing you instead of...
Yeah.
...doing DI.
Yeah, I can't jump too.
Yeah, so that's when you gotta use your other buttons.
What?
Hmm.
They're trying to go to Toshicon pretty bad.
I respect that.
Nice punish, nice punish.
Now you can get in.
Ooh.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, she's got a mix between hit and throw and her wake up.
Let's
see.
Nice walk down to the corner.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
That was an accident.
You're good.
Oh.
There you go.
Nice.
Yeehaw.
Let's go.
Nice.
She's making me very less aggressive, so I'm not used to it.
You're playing well.
You're playing really good, actually.
That's okay.
We take those.
She's backing up a lot, so I'm not used to that at all.
But she's in disadvantage at the wall like that.
Nice!
Get her!
When she corners herself, it's bad for her, so it's okay.
I don't know what to do when...
Because she does like...
Because she anti-airs me too, so it's like...
You can press heavy punch if you have her near the corner.
Oh, I know.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Nice!
Let's go.
Oh.
I'm lucky.
Nice!
Oh my gosh.
Remember, you have level three.
Yeah.
Yeah, next level three will kill.
Oh, I hit that.
I'm lucky.
What?
It's okay.
Oh no!
Okay.
Do I hit that?
Yes.
The legendary!
Do I hit that?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's go.
You did it!
You went undefeated today.
I'm undefeated.
I don't know what to do when she does that.
She's so passive.
Well, you adapted really... I'm... I'm...
I'm serious.
I'm surprised how well you did today.
You did really good.
And you didn't even watch the video.
How the hell?
I went undefeated!
Let's go!
You are a master of neutral.
I'm so proud right now.
You have to keep up the gif streak.
Dude, I gotta fight the final boss.
You gotta fight the raid boss.
I got this.
Gotta cheer him on, dude.
As he enters the fog gate and sees Roy there.
No, for real.
That was good though.
That was wonderful gif gameplay.
It was really good.
Good job.
You ready for this one?
Alright SK, you got this.
Let's do this.
You're gonna mash that tower combo.
You got the mediums and you got DI's to counter.
I'm very nervous today.
I'm playing nothing like I usually play.
That's okay.
You just gotta lean into the nerves.
You know, you can't fight it.
I've been accepting them, you know.
Yeah, me too.
You're gonna be nervous.
It's part of the fun.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
That's fine.
No punish on them.
Oh,
I keep throwing.
I will not throw.
Here we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
That's alright.
Good try.
You're playing great.
Yeah.
Very close.
Nice.
I'm back.
Awesome.
She's crazy.
She burned the meter.
Nice blocks.
Good blocks.
How is this?
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Good grab.
Oh, nice.
Nice punish.
That was unsafe.
Good punish.
Let's go!
Yeah, let's go!
Yeah, that was the medium punch, heavy punch right there that you punish with a throw.
Oh.
Good parries.
Hadouken!
Punish.
Yes.
Good job.
Nice punish.
Oh, I like the baits.
Good one!
That was perfect.
Nice!
And get the super.
All they do is drag and lash.
Let's go.
That felt good, didn't it?
Oh, my god!
You're sick!
Another punish?
He's scared now.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
Yup.
Oh!
Yes!
Oh, my god!
You got the...
You got a stock combo!
You're sick with it.
Yes!
Let's go!
Let's go, SK!
Team SK!
Oh, my goodness.
That was clean.
That was so clean, dude.
Yeah, you got this.
Nice!
Get him!
Oh, perfect!
Oh, the pressure!
That's fine.
She's locked in!
She doesn't expect it twice in a row.
That's right, SK!
You didn't expect the second one!
What about three in a row?
No, actually, don't troll.
Nice.
Super grab.
They were trying to bait the DP.
Oh, no.
She expected it three times.
Alright, alright, alright.
Two is the magic number, not three.
Mid-screen?
Remember, mid-screen blocking is all good.
Chill, chill.
Nice.
Good life.
Woo!
Okay.
Oh, get him!
Nice combo.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, throw a loop on her.
Oh, you know what to do here.
Oh, thank god she messed up.
Yep, that's fine.
Nice!
Good reactions!
Get him!
You got those on player one!
Let's go.
Alright.
They got one more hit.
SK is more confident with the super-each now.
Nice!
Jump in!
You're playing so clean.
Oh, my god.
One more.
Oh, you needed one more.
Oh, god.
Oh,
nice.
Nice.
He got mad.
He went flowchart.
Nice block.
Mid-screen.
So good.
Here we go.
Oh, nice!
Nice.
Jump in.
Oh.
Level three.
That's fine.
I forgot my kick out of that low.
Right.
Sorry, you're still...
You're still in this.
Uh-huh.
Very good.
Okay.
Oh, that might be it.
Oh, ow.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, you're playing very well.
Yeah, yeah.
And you're adapting and...
It's just very good, but I feel like...
Okay, let's go.
I'm done talking.
That's the punish.
There you go.
Okay, let's just bait those out.
She's crazy.
Oh, that combo.
Let's go.
You know these.
Nice, Rob.
Step on in.
Good baits, though.
We dug highs out here?
Very all the confidence.
Nice!
The confidence.
We got this.
One more.
Come here.
Oh, she didn't get him.
Okay, that TP was nutty.
Okay, okay.
All right, all right.
That's fine.
Hadouken.
Nice jumping!
Oh, so good.
I need to block every time.
Yeah, mid screen, just block.
Get him.
Did you punish that?
That's always punishable.
Oh, nice.
That counter DI was pretty good, though.
Yeah.
Level three.
Oh, level two.
That was smart.
Just block mid screen and you got this.
All right.
Last game, last round.
Let's do this.
I believe.
The adaptation, though.
Nice!
Excellent.
Cash out.
Let's go.
That was great defense.
All right, all right, all right.
Did she DP?
Let's find out.
Yeah, she did.
But she's burnt out.
She's burnt out, yep.
Don't do it immediately.
She'll try to jump.
Nice.
Yep, heavy.
Oh, is that death?
Modern is crazy.
That was so close, though.
That was so close.
Yeah, she wanted to jump.
She was burnt out.
Yeah.
That was a good set.
That was a really good set.
Yeah, yeah.
It was very close.
That was really good.
That was my bad.
I'm sorry.
I should have muted myself.
I said heavy punch.
You're cooking.
No, that was my bad.
Sunday's payback day.
I need a fucking Red Bull for this bullshit character, man.
Pop that Red Bull, Miko.
Get that caffeine.
Fuck Jamie, dude.
I hate Jamie.
Remember the notes on this one, man.
Just use your stand medium.
Punch, stand medium kick, crouch medium kick.
And don't do the knee.
And just anti-air his ass.
He's just a jumper.
Yeah, you gotta out-poke him.
Yeah, you're good.
Okay.
Ah,
fuck.
Oh, we went over that too.
Harness the power of the youth.
Believe.
Slap him.
Keep slapping.
Yeah, it's chill.
Just remember.
He's gotta just be in the air.
Just wait for that and there he is.
Okay.
Oh, I tried to jump and he does that.
Yeah, you can't jump there.
Ah, it's just so much to deal with.
I need an opening.
Oh, that's an opening?
Get him.
You heard your call.
Let's fucking go.
Time to party.
Nice.
Let's go.
Fucking go!
I didn't fucking OD.
How did I not OD?
Oh, that was so close.
I thought I did, bro.
Okay, if you're staring him down from a distance too much, dry brush knee.
That's the only other thing you can do.
Okay, got it.
Other than that, use your post a little sparingly.
Don't mash the medium punch.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
We're getting it.
That's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Oh!
That's so good!
Okay, no knee.
Wow, that's really bad, huh?
You can use knee like that.
Just don't do it in neutral and just use a jumper.
That's fine.
He's burnt out.
Yeah.
Nice.
You're gonna be close to burn out.
Oh.
Good try, good try.
That was a good round, though.
That's the rhythm.
He's burning the matchup.
Nice.
Wow, that reached me.
Okay.
Nice.
You got this.
Just hit him and don't let him hit you.
It's that easy.
That's it.
I'm dead.
Am I dropped?
No, yeah.
Good try, man.
Good try.
Thanks, thanks.
It's hard.
It's a hard matchup.
He's keeping his offense real clean.
There's not gonna be the traditional drops and gaps with this guy.
He's playing nice, so you have to not let him get in.
You have to anti-arm him.
You have to convert your offense every time.
Yeah.
Guys, it's a tough one, man.
He's playing good.
That's better than a 1500 MR player.
Swap him.
Swap him for the finals.
They can play the last seed.
Yeah, because I was like, I can take on that DJ.
Give me this DJ.
Make co-fight him.
That was my demon in the last slam.
I'm good, dude.
He's your problem now.
You had to fight his Jhin.
Yeah, I had to fight his Jhin.
Wait, why am I in the queue?
Wait, I thought you were a coach last slam.
Bro, bro, yeah.
Oh, me?
Yeah, you were coefficient.
No, he was a player.
I'm dumb.
Oh my gosh.
There was no team coefficient?
No.
Really?
What?
It's okay.
Roy's team is last place on points or whatever.
I think.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
We've been in your backpack long enough, RallPro.
No, they're not.
They're four.
What do you mean?
We got it.
Let's go, Ko.
Come on, Ko.
Nice.
Oh, man.
Did that kill?
Oh, it does.
That's for sure.
Yeah, that was a good combo.
You're playing good.
Let's go.
You got this.
Nice.
Oh, that's fast.
He messed up his punish.
Let's go.
It's poison.
Yes.
Oh, another throw.
Nice.
Thought I could get it.
Oh my goodness.
That was a sick dub you did.
Ah, I didn't think he was going to cross over.
That's unlucky.
Yeah, that's the DV special.
It's always going to land in front.
Okay.
I mean, you don't see him.
You got your game plan.
Oh, god.
Holy shit.
How much...
DJ has a lot of offense.
Yeah.
Holy...
Nice, you're out of the corner now.
Hmm.
Nevermind.
Yo, mid screen?
Try DI-ing this guy.
He's just fucking flailing.
Doing all that shit?
Like, yeah.
Nice.
Good call.
He needs to slow down.
All good.
Nice.
Here we go.
Another grab.
Give him with that hunter special.
Oh, he learned.
Oh, that was sick.
That was sick.
Yeah.
Careful with your meter.
What?
Is that clean?
Oh, that was so...
That was barely.
Let's go.
Nice.
We take those.
Oh, that's intense.
Avoid burning yourself out if possible against DJ.
Okay.
Yeah.
That might be it there.
Yeah, it might be.
Yeah.
Ah, good try, good try.
Good try, man.
Offense game.
Oh, still alive.
Come back at the century.
Oh, so close.
Yeah, good try, man.
I have...
Yeah, I know that he was lapping this match super hard.
Yeah.
I ran into him a couple times in ranked.
And I beat him every time.
So I know he was lapping the shit out of this match.
DJ's offense is just really good.
Like, you kind of have to stop him before it starts.
If you get cornered, it's almost over.
I was definitely playing a lot more defensively.
And I don't think I should have.
Yeah, neutral, you kind of have to force it.
Like, that's why I said DI.
Like, you just got to go in and make it happen right away.
Because if you get cornered, then it's all downhill.
It's all right.
They're the worst performing team.
No, no, they're not.
They're fourth place.
Don't worry about it.
One of them.
Alright, let's get some more points.
We're doing the worst against the worst team.
They're the worst.
I don't care.
What makes us worse?
I'm just kidding.
I don't give a shit, dude!
Alright, alright.
DJ's gonna laugh against me, guys.
Please.
Yeah, you're definitely the person to beat now, Doki.
No pressure, though.
No, I can't.
I can't, guys.
Nice and obnoxious button, dude.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He just did it.
He's feeling a certain way today.
Man, Jamie players are such crazy nuts.
That's nicer than what I would have said.
But yeah, let's go with that.
I'm trying to keep it PG.
I know.
I'm JK.
Oh, Vic.
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
Oh, nice!
What is that?
Okay, he's burnt.
He has to get out, though.
Nice back dash!
To the corner!
Did he just kill?
Uh, I think...
Yeah, I think if he uses level 1, he can.
It's okay.
He's still burnt.
Nice!
Oh,
nice.
Time to party.
Blitz.
Uh-huh.
Don't be mashing on me, amigo.
Uh-uh-uh.
Safe jump.
Don't be mashing on me, amigo.
Oh, yes!
Just barely built that with that meter.
I saw that.
Never underestimate me.
Jackpot!
Let's get it.
Let's get it!
Woo!
Nice jump, dude.
Stand still!
Oh!
He dropped it.
He messed up.
It was a safe jump, so he couldn't really do much.
Oh, okay.
Oh, nice bait!
Nice!
Yeah, flicker!
Nice counter!
He's almost burnt out.
Oh, he burned himself out!
Let's go!
That's how you go!
He's scared now.
He has to look out for the level 1 now.
Oh, I can't believe that worked.
Oh, my goodness!
Yo, coach is playing real good today, bro.
He's so big, dude.
He's gonna salvage the points here, hopefully.
Nice punt.
Nice.
You're pissing me off!
It's so good, dude.
Woo!
Oh, the low!
Oh, my God!
Scrambled eggs!
Okay.
Back to neutral.
Oh, my God!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Almost clean.
Guys, okay, because of that, we're on a three-way tie with Nephew and Shine.
No shot.
Yeah.
There's no way.
Do we have to play the...
Yeah, the coaches have to play.
No, dude, hold on.
We need auditors.
The other two coaches?
We all have 119 points.
I don't either.
We don't know how to match.
Because Nephew's coach won against Shine's team, so they got another five points.
So now we have a three-way tie.
But what about with Brian's match?
It'll be 119, 119...
So no, how is it a three-way?
119, it's Nephew, Shine, and us.
Oh, so Nephew won, you're saying?
Yeah, Nephew got the coach win, so because of that, they tied it up with Shine.
Oh, shit.
So does that matter?
Do we need to... I guess we do have to...
They're gonna make us replay.
So they're gonna make you guys play, and you have to beat both of them.
Like, what are we exactly doing here?
The first one, apparently the first one to win against the other two coaches is the one that gets to win.
Oh my god, I should've beat Roy, dude.
I should've beat freaking Bald Icon!
Damn it!
I did my job.
We all did our job today.
We all did our job.
We went from tied for third to tied for third.
Yeah, we're all tied.
We won more sets, though.
Like, we lost less the least amount of sets.
Like, Shine's team lost one set more than us.
Yeah, there it is.
Three-way tie.
Are they judging by sets, too, or...?
I think they're just doing points, because the whole idea is that the sets today are worth more.
That's the idea.
There is actually a three-way tie.
That is nice.
Yeah.
Oh, god.
I'm sorry, Brian.
That is crazy.
All right.
I mean, it's time to put on the big boy pants.
Yeah, all right.
This is major focus time.
I'm not talking.
I'm muting.
All right.
I mean, I like the whole, like, cheer like you're the background in Smash Brothers kind of aspect.
That's my favorite part.
All right.
Sounds good.
Don't philosophically get into the definition of neutral.
Oh, my god, dude.
Well...
That's going to haunt me, dude.
Bro, you got to fucking blab against Roy.
Just tell Roy, hey, Roy, why don't you do some sets?
No reason.
You, Ko, or SK are, like, the deciding factor.
Dude, he's tough, man.
I don't know what you're doing.
I'm going to go get some water, guys.
Let me know what they figure out.
Okay.
All right.
He's so good.
Damn.
I did my job so I can chill now.
That's all chill.
But everybody's going to lab against me, so I don't know what to do.
Oh, man.
The slams are so stressful, dude.
But they're fun.
I can't believe how...
I've been to, like, many tournaments before.
And, God, dude, this is something else, let me tell you.
Yeah.
I've hit my zone minutes twice today.
Goddamn.
Yay.
Wow.
Yeah, Doki did real good.
Yeah, she did.
She did.
I did my job.
I'm the only beginner that 5-0'd out of the two days.
Yeah.
They're going to practice hard, though.
They're going to practice hard against Keith.
Yeah.
No, I'm fucked.
Nice.
Something good for SK is if she practices against Ken, that's two of her players that play that character.
Yeah.
That's true.
That's smart.
True.
I lost everything 1-2.
Yeah.
And they're all close.
I just need to get better, and then I will win everything.
That's right.
Yeah.
That is very true.
And the Automatic team, oh, so they are, like, not last.
Diaphones and JB's is last.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I've been saying.
I kept saying that.
Oh, nice.
Which is fucking annoying.
Dude, they could be the first team.
He needs to lock in.
They could be the first in the leaderboards, and I'd still call them the worst team.
No.
Team Jamie, no.
I don't think so.
I know.
And the thing with Roy is his coach mains the character he's using, too.
That kind of sucks to ask.
And so, okay, here's the thing.
If we, this tiebreaker, whoever gets third will have to play Team Auto, right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
We'll have to fight Auto, because they're at the fourth place.
If Bryan, like, loses to both the coaches, then at, I think, Sunday, we'll have to fight that Jamie team in the bracket.
Yeah, we're fighting Auto's team.
If Bryan loses both the coaching matches.
If he wins one of them, we fight, like, Phones' team.
Yeah.
Or JB's.
No, JB's going to be fighting whoever wins two.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep.
So, it's Nephew and Shine.
So...
All right.
If we get one win, we get to fight Phones.
Three-way round robin for tiebreaker invite incoming hostess.
Okay, I got to...
Oh, that's...
Oh, I'm here.
All right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, no.
Hostess...
Where can we watch it?
The mainstream?
Or...
I guess stream.
Can we go in?
You can watch my stream, but it's going to be delayed a little.
Wait.
I'm not going to invite us.
I'm going in.
Oh, no.
That's not it.
No.
All right.
I'll just watch Seijan's stream.
Okay.
Yeah.
And join Seijan's stream and...
Well, you can watch my stream.
If you want to react without me deafening, my stream will be the least delayed.
Okay.
So, it'll make the most sense to me if you react to my stream.
Let's do it.
But then, if I...
All right.
I won't talk.
If you want to.
That's all right.
You're deafening, right?
I don't have to.
I'm just going to keep it to the match only.
Hype moments.
That's it.
Yeah.
Me too.
No philosophical neutral discussions.
I promise.
We'll be like the crowd behind you when you're playing a tournament.
Hell yeah.
Yippee.
Yay.
Except when they root for you to lose.
No.
Oh, no.
That's not fun.
Part of the game.
I mean, we do fight auto.
At best, all of us just need to lab against all the characters.
They said in the chat where this is happening, which is stage two, they said react if you want an invite.
Oh.
Where the fuck is stage two?
I'm reacting.
There's only 16 spots in any of the lobbies.
Come on.
Yeah.
Well.
Come on.
Yeah.
I'm just going to watch.
Honestly, if you watch my stream, it might be less delayed.
It's in stage two.
Stage two.
Ned versus Brian first.
All right.
They said that?
Ned versus Brian first?
Winner first?
Yeah.
They did say that.
Okay.
Stage two.
And then I guess all you guys fight each other once, right?
Yeah.
I think that's the idea.
Because it's a tie.
All right.
Is it two out of three?
I think it is.
Okay.
We're starting now, guys.
They didn't send me the invite.
You got this.
All right.
Amigo.
I'm watching on Brian's stream.
Yeah.
Me too.
I think I'm going to do the same.
They didn't send me the invite.
Me too.
They just started.
It's in 97.
96.
95.
Hmm.
Okay.
What is that grab?
Dude.
I hate jury.
That grab is crazy.
What the hell?
Yeah.
Dude.
I hate it, dude.
That throw loop is insane.
You got it.
That grab.
So good.
You got this.
Adapting time.
Nice.
Perfect parry.
Punish, dude.
Oh.
That grab is so obnoxious.
Yeah.
It's really good.
I hate that even as a gif.
Oh.
Here we go.
Yes.
Let's go.
Come on, coach.
Oh.
That stupid grab.
The loops, man.
Yeah.
Dang it.
It's all right.
All right.
Composure.
No worries.
Nice.
Okay.
Here we go.
You're pissing me off.
Okay.
Yeah.
There you go.
Piss him off.
That's good.
Build some drive gauge back.
Yeah.
Piss him off.
Okay.
Idiot jump.
Still in this.
Oh my God.
It's all good.
All right.
No worries.
We still have the Rasheed match.
So no worries.
These throws, man.
Jury just gets into...
Dude, that shit is obnoxious to watch.
Yeah.
It's obnoxious, dude.
Jury is not fun to fight.
Yeah, dude.
But that's what makes her good.
Yeah.
So what is the idea now?
I don't know.
I think we can wait for the next one.
Nephew is going to fight Rasheed, and then I guess whoever loses it will fight you.
It's the Kim player.
Kim.
Yeah.
Oh, the Kim player.
Rasheed, not the Rasheed player.
Oh, I thought it was Rasheed.
No, that's JB.
He's...
Oh, okay.
So say there's a 1-1 tie.
What happens there?
I think you just keep going.
I don't know.
You keep going?
You keep going, bro.
Because it doesn't make sense for...
Because everybody tied up.
So it doesn't make sense to have...
Oh, Shining and CPT.
Oh my God.
Well, this is...
This is going off the rails.
This is...
This is going nuts.
Oh, no.
They should make him forfeit because he can't show up.
Yes.
Oh.
Okay.
I guess now what we all do...
Oh, that's what...
Sajam's streaming.
Okay.
Shine's stream.
Oh, so we just wait and...
Dude, I'm just going to see your stream of him...
Sajam seeing Shine's stream.
We got stream exception.
There's too much going on here.
Yeah.
So Sajam watching this.
DEQ.
This is...
So...
Doing so fucking much.
People were saying that...
This tournament's very important that he's in.
It resets if Nephew loses the next one.
Ah, I see.
So whoever wins two of them gets to be first.
Well, whoever wins...
No, they'll just play me.
Whoever...
If someone gets to...
Like, if I lose both, then it's over for that person or in general.
Yeah.
So if I win one, it's going to be tied.
And they'll have to keep playing.
So basically, it's all up to Shine.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Dude, I can't believe he's playing in this tournament and doing...
That's a lot, man.
Yeah.
Like, this tournament is super...
It's important.
Like, one of the hardest tournaments in the world, what he's doing right now.
The online one?
Yeah.
Is this specifically NA?
This is for...
This is NA East, which is one of the most stacked regions.
So it had Punk and Mena in it before.
Oh, this is weird.
They don't enter anymore.
Top eight.
So...
Oh my gosh.
Whoever wins this goes to top eight.
Oh, they got it.
Yeah.
So they want points.
Who the hell's in West Coast then?
West Coast is Nephew.
Nephew players like Noah the Prodigy.
Oh, Noah.
Yeah.
And others.
And then Midwest has like Duel Kevin, Just a Kid.
And then I'm in Midwest.
Yeah.
Oh, you got Jack on yours.
So you already get your fill of jury.
Yeah.
I got him last time, luckily.
Wait.
Look.
Nephew.
Magic Pixel from Shine.
Do you know what?
If there's a character that can do it, it's Kimberly.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I think he's going to do it.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
String into super.
It's checkmate.
Checkmate.
Oh my God.
That is insane.
That's actually insane.
It's over.
That's crazy.
He still needs to win one more.
I can't shut up when you guys are playing.
And I need to remember that.
Like, what he just did right there, the checkmate, you guys, all of you have so many moments where it's a guaranteed win and then you let it slip away.
And I'm like...
I get that.
But I just got to shut up.
Yeah.
The checkmate.
This game has a lot of checkmates.
Not me.
Checkmate.
Oh, true.
Okay.
So now it's going to be...
He has to play one more, doesn't he?
Well, it depends on which tournament he holds up.
Yeah.
What's going on here?
Because the other guy won one as well.
Oh.
I am not jealous of Shine right now.
That's crazy what he has to do right now.
Yeah.
Shine entered the room.
Immediately from one crazy match to another.
Two back-to-back.
He is going the distance.
All right.
I mean, to be honest, this is a high-pressure match, but, like, the CPT tournaments are different.
I mean, you lose twice, it's over.
Yeah.
Damn.
Like, a double elimination bracket is a whole other beast.
That's us on Sunday.
Yeah.
Exactly.
The nerves are going to hit different.
Oh, so he's going Ed against Nephew.
Yeah.
Let's see what he does.
Oh, okay.
I just got fucking shimmied over and over.
Oh, you're not playing it at all.
I can't tell you at all.
Okay, yeah.
No, we're just watching the Nephew versus...
I'll pull on...
I'll do it on Sajam's stream.
Yeah, I have.
Same, same.
I'll do the same.
Scouting.
Oh, Shine's playing Ed?
Yeah, he plays Ed too.
Yeah.
He doesn't do the mirror match with the...
He switched Ed.
...with Bry this season.
And he just picks Kim for the mirror match.
Oh, that's interesting.
For certain matchups.
Like Aki.
Against Aki, he was Kim.
He doesn't like Ed mirror?
I think he just tries to win with...
...mirrors in general.
Yeah, mirrors are kind of cringe.
Yeah.
Mirrors are not fun.
I like beef mirrors.
They're funny.
That's like...
That's...
That's uncommon.
It's so funny.
That is very uncommon, Doki.
I like random mirrors.
That's it, though.
I hate dreamers.
Oh, wait.
Dude.
Do you not...
Do you like random mirrors?
I love random mirrors because I win every time.
I see.
Oh, this is really close.
That's...
Didn't...
Didn't Shine beat Nephew on Wednesday?
I don't know.
He beat JB.
I don't remember if he beat Nephew.
No, Nephew was undefeated.
Oh, yes.
I think Nephew went undefeated.
Yeah.
I think Nephew did lose today, too.
No, he did.
He lost to two.
He lost to Diaphone, right?
Oh, he lost two of them.
Yeah.
Lost to Diaphone?
That's an upset.
Diaphone is very good.
Like, a naturally good fighting game player, but he's not, like, a competitive Street Fighter player.
Like, it's not his main game.
Oh, wow.
He plays random selection fighting game.
There you go.
I got it.
That's awesome that he did that.
Yeah.
Oh, that was...
I love that Superman punch.
It's better than Keef's knee over that.
It just can't be plus.
That Superman punch is sick.
Yeah.
It goes over...
It's good for Juri because it goes over fireballs.
Yeah.
I want to play Ed.
That looks fun.
The level two.
Yeah.
Learn it against Roy.
Damn, you too, huh?
It takes a while to get down, I'm telling you.
That combo is not normal.
Yeah.
The desync is kind of hard.
Do you do it on Mudden?
No.
No matter what you do, it's hard because it's a manual timing to get that specific juggle.
Like, yeah.
That's easy to drop.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, unless...
Oh, that's it.
Oh, yeah.
Critical art.
Yeah.
Damn.
When Juri has the...
Yeah.
When she has the stores ready, she can burn them in combos and like...
Oh, he's alive.
Wait.
No, he's dead.
No, he's not.
He forgot the final hit.
Yeah.
If it was regular, maybe.
But CA, no.
All right.
Let's see.
Nephew knows this matchup well, too.
There's the other really good NA is Chris ECH.
He's West Coast.
Oh.
So it's like Nephew and Chris ECH fighting.
So why did...
Oh, Chris ECH.
...Try and pick Ed, though, for this matchup?
Yeah.
Because he doesn't like him versus that.
Kim is not a great character overall.
She's really scrambling fast, but she does low damage.
And in tournament, most characters are like just shitting out damage.
Yeah.
So you have to hit them a bunch.
I see.
So she's really scary, but she's not a consistent character.
So he's trying to move away from Kim.
I see.
Woo.
That overhead.
Oh.
Oh, that's nice.
Clean, clean, clean.
Really good versus Juri.
God.
Yeah.
Superman punch.
Nice punish.
Oh.
How do I make people want to duck my dry brush?
You do the low when you do it.
So they...
Crouching light kick after.
Oh, I never do that one.
Yeah.
Crouching medium kick or crouching light kick?
One of those two.
He dropped the desync there.
Wow.
What a noob.
My coach wouldn't drop that.
I would never do such a thing.
No way.
Speaking of noobs, look at Nephew.
Oh.
That was bad.
That's bad for Nephew.
Damn, dude.
Me.
But wait a minute.
That's me.
Oh, he hits those.
He really called that out?
What the hell?
Yeah.
He would have looked like a scrub if like even that didn't work either, right?
Because...
Can you back dash that after the super flash?
He was too close, I think, to back dash it.
You can back dash it, but I think Nephew recognized the situation that it was guaranteed.
That's insane.
Yeah.
He's really...
Oh.
The counter.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
This is bad.
This is very close.
Oh.
Wait.
This is bad.
Does that kill?
No.
Oh, but he doesn't...
Okay.
This is bad for Shine now.
Yeah.
Oh, that's it.
Oh.
How does Nephew find these, man?
Like, what the...
It's because he quit his job at Google.
He quit his job at Google.
Yeah.
Yeah, dude.
That's the only reason.
He better be finding these.
Yeah.
He left his job at Google.
Come on, guys.
He don't got a nine to five no more.
I'm finding these a lot.
Maybe it's time to quit my high paying...
That's the next level.
That's the next level, coach.
I'm telling you.
Career.
Right next to the piss buff.
It's the quitting your job and the piss buff.
That's how it is.
Well, the thing is Nephew started winning before he quit, so...
No, Nephew was...
I like watching his Colleen in five.
Yeah.
He's always been Godlike.
All these guys have, right?
Like Shine, Nephew...
Oh, yeah.
...JB.
We've been playing Street Butterfly tournaments for so long.
Ooh.
Oh, he could have converted that.
Oh.
Jumping medium.
Nephew's about the style.
I think Nephew is gonna...
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's over.
Okay.
Well, Nephew maybe demoralized him and then I got to play...
You got to play Shine.
I got to play Shine.
Yeah.
We'll see what he does.
God, Shine is going through the ringer right now.
Maybe he'll like mentally break after that, you know?
We'll see.
Okay.
Time to lock in.
All right, amigo.
Get in there.
All right.
Whatever happens, GG's.
Okay.
I should knock Brian's stream.
Absolutely zero pressure.
Yeah.
Zero pressure.
Even if you lose, we will clutch out tomorrow.
Yeah.
No.
Just Saturday.
Sunday.
Sorry.
Fear not.
No fear.
If you lose, we do have to fight the team that killed us, but that's fine.
Guys, I need you guys to lab them because I know they're gonna lab me, please.
I don't know if I can clutch it.
I don't know if I can clutch.
Come on, coach.
Let's go.
All right.
Let's do this, brother.
Team Brian Fury.
Get in there.
Let's go.
Let me use the bathroom.
Too much pressure.
Nice.
I got that jump back.
That was so clean.
There you go.
Okay.
Keep it.
Oh, the jump out.
The flip out.
Spaghetti.
The trades.
Okay.
Ooh.
Got the classic.
Nice.
Ooh.
Good play.
Good block.
Nice.
Ah, yeah.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's it.
No meter for next round.
Let's go.
Those are really good blocks, but yeah, can't block everything.
Yeah, dude.
She's so obnoxious, too, sometimes with her corner pressure.
Ooh.
Good.
Nice.
Good hit.
Let's go.
Let's go, coach.
Get over here.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, good entire.
Yes.
I love the jump low.
Oh, my God.
I love that.
That is trademark Brian Fury.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh, thank God.
That didn't go through.
I know.
Right?
Okay.
Yes.
Big grab.
Oh, yes.
Wow.
Get the drive rush.
Cancel.
Let's go.
Oh, good anti-air.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yes.
Keep him in the corner.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
That trade was not in his favor.
All right.
That's all right.
You're playing neutral like very solid, dude.
Super.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Oh, that's close.
Very close.
So close.
That's close.
Very close.
Still in there.
Oh, good.
Interrupt.
Oh.
Nice.
That's insane.
Uh-huh.
Good blocks.
Hmm.
Okay.
No worries.
Win a bolt.
Ah.
No.
Oh, it's all right.
Good game.
All right.
We'll rap against Otto.
No.
Don't worry.
We're going to learn all tomorrow.
We're going to...
Yeah.
Got it.
They got me this time.
They just jumped at me so much.
I was scared of the elbow drop the whole time.
Yeah.
I didn't see an elbow drop like at all.
No.
All right.
Well, GG.
Well, overall, we played really good, though.
Sorry I didn't clutch it up.
Yeah.
It's all right.
No, we were good, dude.
We got this.
I'm sorry I didn't win more than one match.
It's all good.
I think all of us played so much better today.
I'm sorry I won all five.
We all played so much better today, so I think we should have improved.
Yeah.
Even if we didn't win the same stats or whatever, the game plans are much more consistent.
We're in a good spot.
I'm worried because I feel like a lot of people are going to lab me now because of that.
They will, but just run your game.
Should be okay.
And you don't have to fight everyone against Sunday, right?
You'll have to fight the models.
We have to fight Otto.
Yeah.
And then after Otto, we have to fight either JB or Phon.
We can just fight for those teams then.
We're chilling.
Like, we're for sure fighting Otto?
I don't know if we're fighting.
I don't know.
Yeah, because if they're fourth place, then we fight them.
I don't know if it's like third and fourth play and then fifth and sixth play.
No, usually first fights fourth and then third fights second.
Oh.
Yeah.
It's kind of the same thing.
I don't know.
The higher seed will fight the lower seed.
That's the point.
You should get an advantage for being the best.
Second, we'll fight fifth then.
So who will we fight then?
We'll fight Phon then.
So then we'll fight Dia third.
So we'll fight team Shine.
Sykuna, Morphe, Box, and Dia.
Team Shine then.
Okay, cool.
Oh, Shine.
Oh, we're fighting Shine's team?
Okay, okay, okay.
Are you sure?
Wait, is everybody in winners or do the other teams start in losers?
No, no, no.
Everyone's in winners.
Oh, never mind.
Yeah, but the winner teams get a buy.
Yeah, the winner teams get a buy.
We'll play the fourth seed, we're seed three, and then we'll play the winner of...
I guess...
Well, it depends on...
Normally we'd play seed fourth or if we didn't have a buy, but we have a buy.
So that means...
No, we don't.
We don't have a buy.
I thought only...
No, we don't.
One and two have a buy.
Nephew and Shine have a buy, because that's what happened in Tekken.
Oh.
So then wasn't it third versus fourth?
I thought...
Yeah, this is crazy.
Yeah.
I think we're going to play sixth place.
Oh, we're playing sixth place?
It's third versus sixth.
I think.
Yeah.
We become the seed of the remaining team.
Oh.
So we're just going to be fighting...
We're fighting JB's team.
JB's team.
JB.
Okay.
So Gumi, Ultima, S-Fan, and Cosmonaut.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
God, that's so confusing, man.
It's a little weird.
They'll tell us the final thing.
I guess if we beat JB...
Then we have to win one more.
One more.
Yeah.
So we have to win two to get top four.
Guaranteed.
Okay.
And that buy would have been nice.
Ugh.
It's okay.
Couldn't lock in.
No.
You...
You have some hard-ass...
I mean...
They're jumping so much at me too.
Yeah.
With Shine.
That's so smart.
Because the elbow drop.
He did elbow drop with me so many times in the first match.
He did it more in the first set.
Yes.
And then he switched it up here.
Yeah.
And my DP got baited.
And I was like, okay, don't DP.
Because he's going to elbow drop.
But that's why Kim is annoying to fight as Ed.
It's hard to stop or jump sometimes if you're not super locked in.
Yeah.
That's why I like when you did like the jump back stuff.
It's so...
I'm like, yeah.
Wait.
Yeah.
Jumping back mid-screen is good.
Just avoid the throws.
Guys, all I'm saying is that if we do get to TwitchCon, Shine's team is hella nerfed because they have two VTubers that can't make it to TwitchCon.
I mean, we got...
Who was replacing them?
We don't know.
The two team...
Yeah.
We don't...
The two...
Well, it's replacing them as like two players from the teams that get eliminated.
Oh, true.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Oh, is that how it is?
Yeah.
That's how it is.
That doesn't mean anything.
There could be godlike players in any...
You know, you can't call it.
Yeah.
True.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm just saying.
They're losing two of their players.
Madoki, you'll go, right?
That's all I'm saying.
Because I know we'll be nerfed if you don't go.
I'll never tell.
Oh, we're going to be so nerfed.
We might get buffed, actually.
Yeah, we might.
We don't know yet.
If we can negotiate with Sejam, we might get buffed.
Yeah.
We know a guy.
We just gotta put a wig on him.
He's not going to allow it.
No, he will.
He owes me one.
That's like literally free.
Damn.
He owes me one.
And he knows I'll make content.
He knows I'll give us content.
Yeah.
But with money for other people on the line.
Suddenly you're messing with other people's money.
Sejam might not approve, but we'll see.
We'll see.
It's okay.
I will negotiate if we get into TwitchCon.
Man, I should have won against Sejam.
Wow, dude.
Damn.
What threw you off against him?
I couldn't tell.
I think it's when I was starting to play neutral.
Like, unironically, Doki.
Like, real talk.
Like, when I started to kind of like, feel him out from full screen, that's when I stopped.
Stopped kind of like, I don't know.
I get like very, very...
I don't know.
What's the word for it?
Like...
Apprehensive?
No.
It's like one...
One dimensional.
What the world am I talking about?
I basically stick to one strat and one strat only.
It's like tunnel vision.
That's what it is.
Tunnel vision.
I get tunnel vision on like one strat instead of like trying to go for like other things.
But once my...
I think my offense is really good.
It's just like feeling out the neutral and getting to that offense is what's throwing me off right...
What threw me off in that match.
Yeah.
I mean, you gave him more time to breathe in neutral and then DJ can zone from it.
From a distance.
Yep.
We already came up with the DJ set, right?
Yeah.
No, this is the DJ set in particular.
You give him a chance to zone from a distance and that can be tough for Aki.
Like if she steamrolls DJ, then it's all good.
But if he zones you and then rushes you down, that's like playing into his best game plan.
Yeah.
That's why like you have to just figure out better times to fireball and coward crouch to get the lunging punch or like driver stand medium.
That's the thing.
You still weren't using that much driver stand medium.
And I think that would have been like a godlike burst option to just get in and then driver stand medium into coward crouch, immediate command grab or kicks.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like the burst options had to be a little bit more ready.
But once you slow down, it actually helped him out so much.
Yeah.
So I think that's definitely something I have to work on with him in particular.
I know that he parries a lot, so I'm like, oh, I can...
I think the flow chart that I got works a lot on him, but it's all about like keeping the pressure on.
Right.
Yeah.
Your offense is...
It's crazy good.
If we win our first match, who would we play against?
So we could...
We might be able to calculate.
I'm waiting for the Jam Man to send out the bracket, dude.
Let's see the bracket.
Yeah.
It's getting too complex.
Is he going to send it today or...
Or yeah.
Right now or...
I see.
We'll see.
I think the bracket will be...
We'll have to cook it up.
It might take a little while.
Yeah.
It might be a little bit later.
It's like, how did the Tekken...
Do you remember, Brawl Pro, how the Tekken bracket was like?
I don't remember.
That was a while ago.
Season 4, when the game's out.
It was on his stream.
Oh.
He said it's...
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's out?
All right.
So where is it at?
Where is it?
All right, guys, do you know?
Shine.
Okay.
So if we win our first...
Oh, we have to play Shine again.
Basically.
If they win?
Well, it depends on who wins what.
So overall, they have to buy.
So we're going to go into Shine.
So, we're fighting JB's team and then if we win against JB's team, we have to fight Shine.
That makes sense.
Because they have to buy.
Okay.
We did pretty good against them today, right?
We...
Yeah, because Brian wouldn't have had to...
I won my...
Who's the guy I fought on his team?
You fought...
Oh no, we tied.
Who me?
The JP?
Oh god, that was so annoying.
You fought the JP, yeah.
And then SK fought the ED.
And then I guess...
Yeah, and then I don't remember who Chloe fought.
Who did you fight?
That's doable, guys.
We could probably...
I think I can do that matchup.
We'll...
We'll lab two things, dude.
Like, you got beat by...
Yeah.
Cause like, I don't know...
I don't know, like, how well I'm gonna do on the finals, cause all the beginners are gonna lab against me now.
So like...
Okay, you labbed right.
You know, sometimes I've labbed against you and I've labbed against these players for years and sometimes you just still eat shit.
You know?
So much, and see what happened today.
Yeah.
True.
The only one that got close was the Aki player.
Yeah, cause Aki...
She played a different playstyle than...
No, she's not.
She's definitely a wolf in sheep's clothing, for sure.
She's not bronze.
She's way better than bronze.
She had different combos, and then she actually adapted to my playstyle so I had to like...
From my understanding...
She got coached by broski.
That's the only person I would be concerned about.
Well yeah, she probably also got coached.
She got coached by broski.
Automatic's a really good coach.
I wouldn't count him out either.
He knows the game on such a technical level.
I'd be scared of his team.
That's a lab rat right there.
Yeah, he's really good at communicating and giving tech.
Who's?
Automatic.
Oh yeah, I've noticed bro.
His players will keep leveling up the most.
I think he'll probably be the most efficient coach.
And I think he's doing this like...
He's riding hard.
100%.
Yeah, so Saratina...
Is that who it was?
She is playing the game for real.
She'll be really good soon.
So that's definitely a threat.
Brian, what do I...
You said you don't think he's a 1500 MR player.
What do I do?
Automatic's...
Roy?
I have to play very solid.
It's like...
I can't do anything gimmicky.
Like, you know when you're getting mauled in the corner and you just hate life?
That's just part of the game, man.
He's playing the game.
Sometimes I'm getting mauled in the corner and I manage to fight out and I win and sometimes I don't.
And that's just the game.
So you have to really pick your spots.
And like, for example, you're still not doing Leiried Anti-Air.
If you do not Leiried Anti-Air, you will not be this good.
Okay.
If you block on a wakeup and he neutral jumps to bait your throw and you don't Leiried Anti-Air, you're never getting out of that corner.
It's getting real now.
The later rounds, I started doing it a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll lock that in.
That is the number one thing.
You must have these Anti-Airs because that's going to be the only gaps he's going to give you.
Okay.
Roy is for real.
What about me?
I'm kind of trolling you about him, but he's for real.
What do I need to do?
Don't worry, you're...
Oh, okay.
Dude, real talk, Doki, they're so afraid of you that anything they learn just goes out the window sometimes, you know?
Apparently, Sykkuno was raging a little bit.
He reported me right after.
I would like the clips of that.
I would love clips of Sykkuno.
That guy is too nice for his own good.
Street Fighter 6 will fix him right now.
Bro, he's laughing so hard.
He's like calling on game mates.
He's like freaking telling viewers to play Zangief.
That's so fucked.
Bro, he's actually laughing specifically against Zangief.
We're not even going to play against each other.
I don't think it'll matter.
We're not even going to play.
Well, you never know.
Who knows?
He's fighting modern geese right now, too.
Yeah.
Modern geese, dude.
I mean, yeah.
You just present a problem that is very difficult to solve when you're new at the game, Doki.
That's the reality of it.
That's how it is.
They're just going to have to get much better, everyone at your tier.
And like I said, I think Seratina, she's the one who's like most concerned about beating you.
Is Aki a counter pick to Geek?
It's not Aki.
It has nothing to do with Aki.
This is all 100% universal mechanics and just understanding the flow of the game.
Seratina is the one player that gets the flow of the game as equal as you or maybe, I don't know.
I was looking but she hasn't won a single match so I came in with like...
That's very common.
If you learn the right way to play in the beginning you might just get overwhelmed by people mashing.
But eventually you'll get over that hump and you'll steamroll.
She's playing the long run.
You're mashing like crazy but you're also starting to pick up the flow of the game really well.
You're no longer just a mindless masher.
You're like a scary sort of playing neutral also masher.
It's very difficult for new players to beat you.
It's so hard to read you.
It is.
It's very...
You're very unpredictable.
Yay!
Yeah.
We played Team JB first.
I think we can lab it.
Okay.
Which one is Team JB?
It's the S-Fan team.
It's F-San.
Cosmonaut.
We 4-0'd them.
We played them first every single time.
That's true.
S-Fan does 0-10 but he's playing alright.
He's not playing bad.
He's playing good.
Don't cut him out.
He's also getting additional coaching by Justin too.
And when I play S-Fan next time, I just think he won't fireball.
He would've won but he fireballed and I just reacted to it and jackhammered or whatever.
With S-Fan, he has played fighting games for a long time actually.
I think he's just set in his ways.
He's a boomer.
He's a boomer fighting game player.
You'll run into them and they have habits from 15 plus years of doing the same patterns.
So if something works against them, just keep doing it.
He might change.
There's hope.
But I see this time and time again, dude.
You'll fight people who have been playing Ryu for 40 years and they do the same thing over and over no matter what.
Old man Ryu with the cigarette in his mouth and just mashing away, dude.
Those level 2's are pretty sick though.
I was like Nah, those were clean, bro.
Your matches were nuts.
You were styling.
It was great.
Guys, let's serve our Sykkuno on.
I'm gonna scare him.
A jump scare?
Nah, dude.
You're evil.
He's in the battle of.
He's in the battle of right now.
Whaddup, Sajam?
Thank you.
He's congratulating us.
Oh, he is?
Nice job, gamers.
Thank you, Jamman.
Yeah, good stuff running the event.
It's been fun.
It was fun.
Yeah, so do you guys want, like, more notes or anything, or just try to sync up tomorrow?
Does anyone care about the written stuff?
I want, like, notes on, I guess, like, Shine's team.
I think Gumi, I sort of understand how she plays now, but I think, like, if it kind of stops jumping, I might be like, I might get a little confused if she stops jumping.
Right.
Yeah.
Cause, like, I'm basically taking advantage of her jumps, basically.
I honestly think she will keep doing that, and I think we just get even better at beating that.
That's what I think.
I'm probably gonna lab against Cosmonaut's Ken just to see how he plays, cause even though, like, I won both times, I'm still, I don't want any surprises.
The only thing you gotta lab, dude, is medium, medium punch, cancelled into light demon flip into the chop.
He does it over and over, and when he comes down, he does it...
This is for Cosmonaut, his Ken.
Oh, Cosmonaut.
Both times, but I'm still, like, I still wanna be prepared, and then, oh, absolutely, I need to lab out that Akuma magic, for sure.
Yeah, you should beat him.
I might even try and do, like, the jump back stuff that you were saying.
Like against, like, demon flip chop.
Is that him?
Huh?
Someone made a meme, I haven't watched it yet, though.
Is this Sykkuno?
Okay.
Sykkuno hunting.
I'm gonna be packing it up here, squad.
Good shit, everybody, today.
I'm gonna quit stream.
GG.
GG's, everybody.
GG's, guys.
Good luck with the labs.
GG's.
I'll be on tomorrow, so let's sync up, let's do whatever.
Let's get it done.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Have a good one, guys.
Bye-bye.
Okay.
I was surprised how well I did today.
I mean...
I mean, we're gonna be playing as JB, so I'm not too worried.
I mean, I don't know, actually.
I don't know.
It depends on how hard they lab against me.
Oh, well done!
That's me!
Your fans are congratulating me!
Sykkuno!
Yippee!
Oh, my God.
I was very surprised.
Honestly, I'm very surprised I managed to 5-0 today.
I think I'm like the only beginner that 5-hoed.
So, like, I did not expect that because I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know!
Like, people think I have a strategy going in, but I'm playing very reactive.
I'm just...
I'm just playing super reactive when I'm...
when I'm playing Street Fighter.
So, like, I'm very... I was very surprised.
But, yeah, I think, like, as long as my team... I don't know.
The thing I'm worried about is that everybody is, like, labbing... will be labbing against me.
So, like, that's what I'm really worried about.
I don't give a fuck what Street Fighter would play.
I play safe.
Because, like, they're easier...
A lot of the characters that people are playing requires you to jump.
Like, it requires them to jump.
And, like, I'm very good at, like, countering jumps.
Yep, he's gonna, like, lab me.
Okay, Axis.
Join queue.
No!
Everybody's joining!
I can't!
Everybody's in the queue!
I don't think he noticed.
No, the queue is huge!
How's he doing, though?
Is he okay?
I don't understand why he's labbing me!
We're not gonna fight!
That's the thing!
Like, I don't know why!
Like, we're not gonna be matched up at all, so there's, like, no reason for him to have to lab against me!
He's literally not!
Like, I play Gumi, and then I play Kanna.
Like, we're not matching up!
Like, he's not even gonna see me at TwitchCon!
Like, he's not gonna fight me at TwitchCon!
That's the thing!
I broke him!
You might break him right now!
Oh my god!
It's not about the tournament at that point!
Bro, he already beat a Gief, though!
Like, there's no way he has not won!
No, see?
He already beat a Gief!
Not every Gief knows what they're doing!
Oh, that's embarrassing.
It's personal now.
Also, guys, I won't be streaming it, but I got invited to a collab for tomorrow.
I think it's Monopoly?
I don't know who's streaming it.
I think it's, like, EleM invited me.
It was really sweet of him, because he was like, EleM from Twitch Rivals yesterday, he was like, Oh, you're so funny!
You wanna do this collab?
And I was like, okay.
It's like Monopoly with him, NiceWig, Sykkuno, and IronMouse.
So, I won't be streaming it, but I'll be showing up.
He even tried to invite me to like, a lockdown protocol collab today, but I was like, I can't, buddy.
I have to do Street Fighter.
Oh, poor Sykkuno!
Oh, that shit's toxic.
Oh, that shit's toxic!
Damn!
Oh my god!
That shit is so toxic!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
Wait, where did Sykkuno go?
Where did he go?
Is that him?
Hey.
No!
I wanted to join you!
Oh, I'm on the... Oh, nice.
Okay.
Um...
Sure.
There we go.
EG.
No, guys, I'm gonna do something really...
Guys, I'm gonna do something super toxic.
Please stop harassing this poor man.
No, no, it's gonna be worse than a one and done.
Oh, man.
I'm just surprised that I... I'm... Like, I was even the only person he lost against.
I...
Like, I don't understand.
He lost against... Who did he lose to?
He lost to...
Okay, where's Sykkuno's matchup?
Okay, pink.
He lost to... He lost to Shine as well!
He lost...
He lost to Shine!
And... Oh, wait, and me.
That's me.
Yeah.
He lost to Shine.
I broke him.
That's pretty funny.
I'm just happy.
I'm just happy that I did the best because a lot of people think I'm not that great at fighting games.
So, like, this is to prove the haters wrong.
I still am not that good at fighting games.
But, like, my one moment to Shine.
My one moment to Shine.
Yeah.
I opened my third eye.
Um...
Am I having fun with Street Fighter?
I think... I still think King is more fun to play.
Because, like, the reason...
The difference between me playing King and me playing Zangief... Like, I actually have to be very aware of what I'm doing.
So, like, um...
I have to be... I have to... I still have...
I have to, like, think reactively.
As King, I... It's very easy to button mash.
So, like, I'm...
I'm more... I like that.
Like...
I like... There's more cheese when it comes to King.
And, like, the game is much more fast-paced.
Playing King lets me play super fast.
Playing Zangief, I have to balance between fast-paced and slow.
And I hate that.
Like...
Like, I play King super head-empty.
But on Zangief, like, I can have a conversation.
I can have a conversation while playing King at the same time.
Because, like, I can literally be, like, like, head-empty and stuff.
Um... But, uh... For Zangief, I actually have to focus and be like, okay, what is he gonna do?
What do I think he's gonna do next?
I do a lot of prediction on Zangief.
Like, I do reads a lot.
Like, a lot of people say, like, wow, she's...
Because, like, people said that I was very lucky with the... with that throw on the first round.
Oh my god, Sykkun, and that's...
People say I did it, like, luck.
But, like, I... It was reflex.
It was... Like, not reflex, but it was, like, um...
Wait, who am I requesting to fight?
I don't... Oh, no.
Not you.
Wait, where's...
Where's Sykkun?
No!
I wanted to fight!
I...
No!
I lost a cube!
I lost it!
Wait, where is he?
Where did he go?
I lost it!
No!
Wait, did he...
Wait, he left?
No!
He actually left.
Bro...
Fuck.
I can't believe he...
He joined!
Wait, which server?
Which server?
I wanna fight him!
Which server is he?
He...
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god.
There he is.
I just wanna do the thing.
I just...
I wanna leave and do the thing.
Oh, I think everybody joined the queue.
You menace.
I just wanna... I just wanna...
I just wanna do the thing.
Oh my god, this queue is too fucking long.
This queue...
This queue is too long.
I can't...
They're protecting him.
Wait, but...
Didn't he say he'll end the stream after he wins against the GEEF?
Like, didn't he say that?
And he's still streaming.
Like, he's still stream...
Alright...
Wait, has he actually?
Oh my god.
I feel bad.
Like, I mind broke this guy.
Like...
Holy shit!
He did that on... Bro!
Bro, even Braum doesn't know how to do this on Classic!
Oh my god!
He's so... Bro, this guy's better than me!
Bro, he's actually...
Oh my god!
He's actually... He's still queueing.
Bro, this guy is better than me!
He's a legit GEEF.
The fact that he did it on Classic was insane.
Cause Braum doesn't know how to do it on Classic.
Like...
He's dead.
Real GEEF.
Yeah...
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Poor guy!
Bro, he doesn't deserve this.
He actually doesn't deserve this.
Is he okay?
Like, Kudo, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Okay...
Does he want to fight me?
I'm literally the GEEF...
Like, the GEEF that he wants to beat.
Okay...
Alright...
I waited so long to do this.
I waited so long...
to do this.
Wait!
This is not...
This is not Sykkuno.
This is...
Whoops!
Alright!
GEEF versus GEEF.
Let's let him go.
I think fighting a GEEF is so funny.
Like, the mirror match between two GEEFs.
Oh my god!
This guy actually knows what he's doing, though.
The GEEF versus GEEF.
It's so goofy.
It's actually so goofy.
Oh my god!
This guy knows what he's doing.
He's a classic GEEF player, guys!
This guy was gonna beat the shit out of Sykkuno no matter what!
He's on classic.
He knows.
Bro, he actually knows.
This is like me fighting BrawlPro.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, I'm not green.
I thought I was green for a sec.
Guys, he's good.
He actually knows what he's doing, guys.
What?
What is that?
Oh my god!
He jumps!
GG's.
There was no way.
That steal is dead!
Okay, where is he?
Where is he?
Oh my god!
He jumps!
Where the fuck is he?
Where the fuck did he go?
That GEEF butted in!
Okay, where is he?
Don't worry, guys.
I know what I'm gonna do.
Where the fuck?
Bro, he was definitely not gonna win against that GEEF.
That GEEF actually knows what the fuck he's doing.
There was no way.
The GEEF I just fought knew exactly how to play.
Oh, there he is.
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
I'm gonna do something very toxic, guys.
I'm gonna...
Watch this.
I'm gonna do something very toxic.
...
Okay, watch this.
Oh, wait, actually let me just do this real fast, though.
...
Let me just do this real fast.
Okay.
Oh okay, I just needed to...
Alright.
Goodbye!
Whoa!
Watch this.
No way!
You can't kill me one round in a row.
You can't unplug your internet!
That's not legal!
What the?
I couldn't choose.
Who is this guy?
What the?
Is that Chipotle Burrito?
I waited.
I waited a whole...
I waited a whole time to do this!
If I could do this once.
This is insane man.
That is insane.
How do you play this game?
How does anybody play this game?
Look at that guy!
That's me!
That looks like Zangief.
That's a picture of me right now.
George thank you for the superchat.
You're so nice.
Smile while you play everybody.
You gonna die?
I didn't learn how to play.
How many Q's has he FOUGHT so far?
He has a green ring.
You're so crazy!
That's mine.
Your so crazy.
So evil.
Alright, that's how I want to end today's stream.
GG's everybody, we 5-0'd today.
I did pretty well in the beauty's division.
Thank you all for supporting and watching!
I really appreciate it.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!